This is Jocko podcast
number one 86 with me,
Jocko Willink.
Among the newly minted
Special Forces soldiers were
Douglas El Latino, a skinny hundred
and 35 pound California cowboy,
John Shore, a blonde haired,
slightly overweight baby faced kid
from Georgia and frank mccloskey,
a tough combat hardened veteran of
the a hundred first airborne division.
Mccloskey arrived sporting seepage
from a wound in the back of his head.
This trio of green berets had completed
their special forces in country training
program and not train the Fifth
Special Forces Group headquarters.
When a sergeant not training asked for
Special Forces soldiers to volunteer for
a secret project,
they raised their hands in short order.
They were flown to fob four in the
northern sector of South Vietnam.
ICORE upon reporting in,
they were told Camp Commander Colonel
Jack Warren would brief them in the
morning on the CNC
mission in Southeast Asia.
Finally, after more than a
year of training for Laterno,
the game was on how much
better could this get?
It seems all his life he'd been preparing
for this moment from riding rodeo
Bronx and breaking nearly
every bone in his body.
To wrangling animals for television
shows like Dak Tare and cowboy in Africa
starring Chuck Connors.
Laterno knew a little bit
about taking a calculated risk.
Okay.
And after he had gotten his hands on
Robin Moore's book, the Green Berets,
he knew this was for him.
Guerrilla warfare. Check,
counterinsurgency training,
check unconventional warfare,
check return. Oh,
couldn't wait to write his own story that
he could someday share with his dad a
world war to be 17 pilot and former POW.
Nothing,
however could have prepared him for the
site that greeted him as he entered the
transient barracks there etched onto
the concrete floor and forever in his
memory was the chart
outline of a man's body,
a grizzly reminder of the 23 August,
1968 attack on fob for
that fateful evening,
north Vietnamese sappers and Vietcong
operatives killed 18 green berets in a
carefully executed sneak attack.
The deadly side of gorilla warfare
was brought home to him right there.
He was in a war zone. The enemy
didn't play by any set rules.
It was an unsettling event. The
next morning after breakfast,
the trio walked over to s three
and chose their code names.
The Tourneau mccloskey and shore
now became the Frenchmen, nam, Mu,
and bubba names that would stick with
them far beyond their tours of duty in
Vietnam because S3 was temporarily
located in the headquarters section of fob
four since the attack,
it was a quick shuffle into the
briefing room with everyone else,
an intense short,
an intense short black haired man wearing
pajamas slippers and a bathrobe walked
in smoking a cigarette
before a word was spoken.
Colonel Warren abruptly pulled a white
sheet off a large map with a flourish and
tossed it aside and announced.
Welcome to C and C men turning to the
large map that had black tape boxed
target, deadly designators on in Laos,
the DMZ and north Vietnam. He continued.
This is what you volunteered for.
This is why this is a top
secret project. If anybody asks,
the president can say, we have
no men stationed in the AOE.
That is why you'll wear sterile fatigues
and carry no form of identification of
any kind on your missions.
That's why you agreed not to talk
to anyone about this operation.
For at least 20 years,
our Intel reports land in the
White House. Any questions?
Not Waiting for a response.
Warn continued to explain the difference
between spike teams and hatchet force
elements where the
different fops were located.
How fob three at case on was closed after
the siege earlier in the year and how
major Clyde's sincere jr had opened a
site at my lock now designated fob three
following an update on intelligence
reports in the respective areas of
operations. Colonel Warren asked
if anyone had any questions.
The turno raised his hand.
Where do you need help, sir?
We need men at fob one we lost a one
zero on October 5th and some of the first
special forces, TDY troops from Okinawa
are returning back to the island,
the turnoff short turn to shore and
mccloskey and asked, how about it fob?
One shore nodded in the
affirmative. Mccloskey said, no,
I think I'll stay here. Latino
turned back to Warren and said,
we'll go nodding towards
shore. Surprised at mccloskey.
His response without missing a beat.
Warren told the remainder of the SF troops
in the room that he'd be right back.
He turned to Latino and
shore and said, follow me.
As he headed out of the briefing room
and into the s three operation center,
he told the center staff
to get a king, beat a fob,
four in an hour to transport
Latino and short to fob one asap.
Next he headed to s one and told the clerk
that the newbies were to be processed
and cleared to go to
food by an hour later,
PFC Latino and Spec for shore.
We're in a King B heading north to fob one
and that right there is an excerpt,
the book across the fence
which was written by
John Stryker Meyer nickname tilt,
who is a special forces soldier and
saga recon leader in Vietnam and we went
deep with tilts on podcast one 81 81 and
one 82 and if you haven't listened to
those podcasts and stop this one right
now and go back and listen to those
first.
But if you have already listened to
those podcasts and you heard a little bit
about Doug Latino code name the
Frenchman and you know that he was also a
special forces soldier at Green Baret
and it was also a SOG team member in
Vietnam and it is an absolute honor to
have not only tilt back again on this
podcast, but he brought
with him the man himself.
Doug Laterno. [inaudible]
gentlemen, thank you for coming on.
Good to see you again. Good evening sir.
Good evening. Thank you for having us.
They had great tribute to your, great
to have you both here and um, yeah.
Let's talk a little bit about how you
ended up there. I mean we, you glow,
you glaze over in the book.
We're, we're riding Rodeo Broncos.
We're working in Hollywood,
taming and animals.
What was your upbringing that
got you to, that got you there.
Believe it or not, I was
born east la in the Barrio.
Well that makes sense.
Yeah, not, yeah, I know. No.
So living in the city.
I got fortunate enough when
I got into high school,
then I got into a program called
the future farmers of America.
And it gave me a whole different
way of looking at life.
And I ended up becoming a
president of the chapter,
but I had several Spanish
speaking in Spanish,
people in our chapter, one of the
largest in all of southern California.
As it turned out, well with these people,
I could became such good friends and
their way of life in still working in the
fields of the San Fernando
valley, which was still open. Uh,
I tended to lean towards
the country way of life,
even though I was born
and raised in the city.
And I do nothing about
anything at all but city life.
But I tried to break away
from that through the
organization and the western end
of the San Fernando Valley.
Well, one thing led to another,
and I learned about you could go rodeo
and there was a place that I could go
ride in practice.
We could do bull riding and bronc
riding and bareback riding and, uh,
all the three w [inaudible]
San Fernando Valley.
This was actually out in thousand
oaks at the paramount studios. Okay.
Yeah. They had a ranch
right there. And, uh,
w d coopers is what it was
called in those days. And, uh,
we could go out on Wednesday night
and Saturday and Sunday and ride
and have jackpots. And I got into it
and then one thing led to another.
I got into college and I got on the
college inner collegiate team and we
traveled and rodeoed. And, and
as I went through college, uh,
I became adept to it and got into roping
with roping horses and own my own rope
horse. And it just, the way of life
changed from being a city slicker to a,
to a cowboy. Where'd you go to college?
I started out at Pierce Junior
College at the, in Woodland Hills,
San Fernando Valley,
and then ended up with cal
poly San Luis Obispo mustangs.
So it through courses there. And, uh,
but basically, uh,
we just just kept on going. And then
with the TV series is we're
popular when a lot of animals,
there was an opening to be a
wild animal trainer at Africa,
USA in San Canyon. Newhall.
So I jumped up there.
How old are you at this point? I'm nine.
I'm 20 and while the animal
trainers sounds like, you know,
you're talking another day
in college. There you go.
So I jumped up there and before I
knew it I was handling Clarence,
the cross sided line and Judy the chimp.
And then they had a rope horse there
that they used and they wanted me to call
Dakota Duke and they wanted me to go out
and capture all these animals by roping
them. And they knew I could rope.
There's actual picture of me on the
front of the pigging string that was
produced out of Lancaster,
Antelope Valley of me on the
front cover of roping a tiger,
often this off of words off this
horse. And that's what I did.
And I wrote the elephants and
I wrote, you know, healed them,
healed giraffes.
And I headed up White Rhino
Forum and that was coming at us.
And I turned them back and you know,
where they, they would do all these, uh,
what they call a veil avail. It'd be
open land. It's a, it's an African term.
And, uh, we just, uh, would
turn these animals loose,
but somebody had to go get them. So
I, I actually got to work on the,
on the TV series that was
very popular, called doc tare.
And people would see the
trucks, they were zebra trucks.
I went on Youtube and checked
out some doc tare, own footage,
classic show really. And uh,
but it was shot in like Africa,
but actually it was all done right
there in New Orleans songs, you know,
the compound. And so from there, uh,
we ran into a series called the
cowboy in Africa and we brought chuck,
Chuck Connors in it. And uh,
he was the star. And, uh,
Hugh O'Brian had actually
done the original movie.
There's of cowboy in Africa
and they shot it in Africa,
but here they are going to shoot it
here in the United States. And, uh,
so I got to work with ostriches and all
kinds of different animals that they had
to have around the,
the compound of the House that he
was working out of in the series.
But one thing led to another.
But as it turned out, uh,
one night somebody handed
me an old ragged book,
it's called the Greenbrae,
but Robin Moore and I looked at it and
read it and I couldn't put it down.
And I said,
this has got to be something that this
Vietnam War's been going on for quite a
while. I grew up almost
listening to it every day.
There's gotta be something going on that
I need to contribute and I think this
is what I want to do. I went down the
next day, very next day, and signed up.
What year was that and how old were
you? I was 20 and this was, uh,
like a September, just
before it was like, well,
I say, cause I went in September
1st so it was the day before.
So August, you know, August 30th.
What year though? 1968.
1960 67 67 years.
And I actually entered the
service in of September 1st,
1967.
Yeah. By that time he had
obtained a college degree
by tending classes at night.
So instead of going through to four year
program, the college of three years,
well I graduated when I was 17,
from high school, from high school.
Guy was early into classes at
night. Yeah. As spare time. And,
and like the,
the attitude towards the
Vietnam War in 1967, you know,
from the, I mean, spread when
we think a Hollywood now we,
we think of people that
just are, you know,
just detest everything that has to do
with the military most of the time.
And you were kind of in that Hollywood
scene hanging around with all these
people, but that didn't
rub off on you at all.
It didn't happen that way in 67, 68.
It wasn't like that back then.
I was shocked when I got
back and I actually, uh,
visited Bubba in on
Peach Street in Atlanta,
Georgia. And there was a anti, uh,
rally Vietnam rally going down the street.
And I looked out the window and I
said, Bubba, what in the world is that?
He says, those are anti war
protesters. I'd never seen it,
never heard of it. But in 67,
everybody was still pretty patriotic.
Got and didn't have that situation.
And, and now what about your
old man who was, you know, he,
he was, you were raised as a son of
a guy that was a [inaudible] pilot.
Yes. A, a war hero in itself. He was,
he ran 13 missions.
He was actually the first two
missions in were over Berlin.
He was on the first two missions
that bomb Berlin itself,
but he flew 13 missions
on his 13th mission.
Uh,
they gave him a brand new airplane because
his airplane had been shot up so bad
with his crew that he brought from the
United States and flew it over to England
that they had to give him a
brand new airplane that morning.
And he took off and he
had 999 planes behind him.
He was point that day and he went
over a target called Schweinfurth.
As it turned out,
Schweinfurth in four in 44 had lost
56 airplanes and this day his entire
squadron of 22 out of 23 where
to be shot down that day.
And he was the first one down and they
were using new tactics the Nazis were
with. They would line up, uh,
Mr Smith's and one oh nines and, uh,
in a row and go right through them instead
of coming around or calling on top,
they'd just go right through them.
They didn't care if they
lost the planes or not.
And then they had a folk with one
nineties behind them and they took out all
these planes in the very lead
just to start the battle.
But no one could ever figure out why
Schweinfurth was so protected and so many
losses every time it was tried to be
bombed and Garrick during the Nuremberg
trials,
he admitted that it was the only ball
bearing factory the Germans owned without
ball-bearings. A war would have been
over with in a matter of a few months.
And this whole war went on and on and on
because neither the British or the u s
could figure, figure that out.
And they should have bobbed
it every day is what he said.
And if the war would've been over
with, they would have had to surrender.
But just the cork in the whole situation.
But my dad ended up being
my first airborne person in
our family in voluntarily
in the fall of two.
And Halo told themselves one altitude
when they find that 10,000 feet when he
jumped because his plane caught on
fire and they couldn't extinguish it.
His engines were on fire and he
couldn't open the Bombay doors.
The hydraulic system had been shot up.
He'd lost his radio operator had a a 20
millimeter right through his stomach and
they had to put a parachute on him and
just shoving him out the bottom door.
And, uh, it was pretty, pretty
hectic. The plane blew up in mid air,
but those that could got out and made
the free fall to the ground and I'll pull
their shoots. And, uh, anyway,
my dad was attacked by
farmers with pitchforks.
And thank God that Gestapo and the ss
were there to retrieve him and push the
farmers back. He thought he was
gonna die right there in the hole.
He sprained his ankle and he was kind
of out of it. And, uh, but anyway,
they hauled him off and strung him up
and tried to make him talk and you know,
the usual serial number, name and rank.
And then they put him install log one,
which was an all officer camp and had
15,000 officers that had been shot down in
that camp.
All the enlisted men went to enlisted
stall logs and he served 13 months in the
POW camp. And then one morning they
woke up and the Russians were there,
the Russians liberated them. And, uh,
he was taken home. And
that's the story. And,
and uh,
he became well known for in
our town for what he did.
Plus he had two brothers and my uncle
Arman was given a silver star by Patton,
General Patton himself in
France, pinned [inaudible] chest.
And my uncle Eddie flew corsairs or
so the Latino brothers were quite active.
They were. So I had a lot to follow.
Jeez. So I ran, I ran 13 missions.
How Ironic, right. I ran 13
missions and one bright light.
W when your dad came home, what did he
do? When did he get out of the army?
Did He, well it was the army air corps
in those days. It wasn't the air force.
And uh, so he, he uh,
he tried doing a little bartending
and a little this, a little of that,
but he had been in construction.
He actually partnered up with,
is it my grandfather? My,
my grandparents and it was Latino
and Latino construction company.
And uh, he,
okay.
Filtered back into the construction and
started building because they needed
homes, every, all of these
soldiers coming home.
And he built most of the Burbank
and Glendale at the time. And uh,
they did always did quite well and
got into commercial buildings and,
and uh,
I sort of followed into those footsteps
eventually after I got back from the
service. So when you, when
you enlisted, what did you,
how did your dad feel about that? Well,
he was not happy about it cause
he only gave him a day's notice.
I said, I'm going,
I'm going into the service and I'm going
to go to Vietnam and I'm going to be a
green baret. But of course when we and
I enlisted, they couldn't give me that.
It was the only mos, uh, that
they could not give because a,
it wasn't guaranteed. They could
guarantee me anything else.
They wanted to be an officer because
I had a degree and I said, no,
I'm not going to go to ocs. I want to,
I want to go and be whatever it
takes to be in special forces.
As it turned out in the long run,
whether you really want to hear the
whole story, it's up to you. But, uh,
I did end up being a green baret and
going through all the processes and going
through all the volunteer
and being accepted and going
into it and I passed it.
But during that time, I'm, you have
to realize I'm just an [inaudible].
I went in as an [inaudible].
I'm an [inaudible].
I'm the lowest ranking there is. And,
and the Mos that I actually graduated
with was a prized mos that only a few
would maintain and that was
heavy weapons. And they go,
you can't be heavy weapons unless
you're an [inaudible] or above.
But when my turn came up to
go in front of the panel,
my name being an l that's
made it documented.
That's why I can say this.
I was the first [inaudible] ever to
be accepted for weapons, Mos training
and cause I, I told them exactly
what I had in mind. I said,
come Monday morning,
we've already gone through our phase
one and I've gotten my green baret and I
said, we need to go into mols
and how this Monday I can start.
I said,
when that Mos has done is so happens
phase two of graduation exercise though
when you're go out in the field for
two weeks in survival mode. I said,
it will start immediately the
following Monday. And I said,
and I can be in Vietnam
in the next three months.
And they looked at me
and said, you got it.
So if you look at the orders,
everything from l dizzy,
there was e e Two e three e four was
in my weapons class because I started
something that couldn't be turned
back. The tide had been turned.
So when I got to Vietnam and
my first assignment to fob one,
I'm now a PFC e three and Pat Watkins
who has the DSC distinguished service
cross from his uh,
time on August 23rd when
the fob four was attacked.
He told everybody there must be one bad
son of a bitch coming up here because
he's a PFC. He's 11 Charlie s SF.
He said he's been busted down so far.
He's gotta be the baddest
soldier working on the land.
When I showed up and he
looked at me, he goes,
you are a PFC.
Cause I as green as
grass and knew nothing.
Just been trained on ah, that's a
good, that's a good way to kick it off,
man. You're welcome. That will
be one. Yeah. Yeah. What did you,
when you were going through
the trip, how long was the,
how long was the block of training
that you, so you go through bootcamp,
how long was the SF training?
Was that total? Well,
I had to go through bootcamp and that's
where I had to volunteer to even be, uh,
go through the acceptance
of trying to be a, uh,
assigned to SF training.
Then I went into advanced ait,
which is advanced infantry training.
You had to go through that and you also
had to sign up for airborne training.
So you had to go through all, all
the basics and come out as an 11 B,
which was a small infantry, uh, arms.
So anyway, uh,
then jumps to, yeah, jump
school, but I went through that,
the nomination part of taking tests
and physical tests and swimming,
everything.
And then interviews with the SF guys
that were there that were in charge of
selecting who was going to go.
We started out with 350 men volunteering
to go through this acceptance.
They only took 35 and the end of the deal,
I was one of the 35 and I went on to
airborne school the next day and went
through jump school at Fort Benning,
Georgia. They put us after our last jump,
which was out of the old
boxcar one nineteens and then
they came in with the new
jets. And, uh, so I, I,
I've kind of proud of that.
And we went on a bus that night all the
way to Fort Bragg and got there in the
early morning hours of
Saturday, uh, Saturday morning.
And then Monday morning we
were in formation for our
very first day of training
in, in special forces.
And that, that block,
there was two weeks out in survival phase
one and then eight weeks of training
after that.
And then another two weeks
of our graduation exercises
where we're trained to
overtake a government. That's
what special forces does,
is actually over takeover governments
and train gorillas to do so.
And uh, so then 30 days
later I was in Vietnam
was the the, I'm sure the focus
must have been like 100% on, hey,
you're going to Vietnam. We
know you're going to Vietnam.
This is what it's going to be like.
This is what you're dealing with.
When I graduated [inaudible],
the colonel stood in front of us,
the head of all of trading group and said,
I don't want a one of you to volunteer
for Fifth Group spent Vietnam.
We spent too much money on you.
You're just going to go there and die.
You stay here. Pick any other group.
I'm going to go down the line with the
command sergeant major and he's going to
tell me what group you want to go to.
I had 23 graduates in my class,
all but three volunteered for Vietnam.
He was not happy.
What I'd like you to think like why does,
why is someone during the Vietnam War
going to join special forces unless they
want to go to Vietnam? I mean
exactly, but in my mind
there was something wrong.
It had been going on for years.
[inaudible] and special
forces had been there before.
It was a bit a war advising and
I just could not figure that out.
And I said, I've got to go. I've
got to see why it's taken so long.
It's taking longer than the World
War II and that was five years.
So why is it taking so dang long?
So I said I've got to get there and
do something about it. That's how I,
my attitude was, okay,
French prince comedy is going to
handle this today. I'll see. Oh,
I see. Yeah. Yeah. All right, I'm going
to go to the book here. Go. This is,
this is going back to across
the fence and I'm obviously,
I told everyone to buy this cause
I've been reading chunks of it.
And if you haven't bought it
yet, just buy it right now. Um,
written by John Stryker Meyer.
So this is a section where he's,
he's writing about the Frenchmen.
So here we go. Within 24 hours.
The turnover in store.
We're on recon teams at fob one and the
immediately began training immediate
reaction drills, weapons and explosives
training, reviewing team slps,
practicing helicopter extractions on
strings and practicing wiretaps as October
yielded to November.
Many of the members of the two recon teams
began to build a rapport because they
were doing so much training together
on the food buy range in addition to a
Tourneau insurer.
Also quickly learned that the veteran
indigenous personnel on their teams were
highly skilled and fearless warriors.
One night while the turbo was recording
a verbal message for his parents on his
portable cassette player lap.
The young point man on s t Virginia
came into his room and spoken to the
recorder. I want to tell you,
parents have private Latino
not to worry about him.
We respect him and I'll keep an eye
out for him and don't worry if an enemy
shoots at him. I'll catch the bullets
with my body. I'll protect your son.
Thank you for sending him to
Vietnam. He's a good soldier
that he was,
the kid was like 16 years
old and he was our point man.
Who knows how many kills
he had. He was fearless.
His parents had been both killed.
He was an adoptee in the song.
He was raised and lived and
fought and saw. Ugh. Wow.
And he prided himself on trying to learn
how to speak English because he wanted
to be number one interpreter.
Yeah. How'd your parents like
that? Did they ever get the tape?
They got the tape. Yeah.
I wish I knew where they were that they
passed away and we couldn't find him.
But uh, yeah, it was amazing.
And my dad knew right then and
there I wasn't coming home.
Yeah.
He knew I wasn't coming
home and he didn't,
he had to try to keep my
mother from figuring that out.
But he knew that I would not be let come
Paul because of the secret missions.
He figured they would,
the government would take me out before
they would let me come home with what I
knew. Hmm.
And Lap as a kind of Vietnamese southby
amuse ally that you never heard about
[inaudible] that we worked with
every day. And we're alive today.
Thanks to them. [inaudible]
we are alive to them. Oh yeah, we do.
And a couple of [inaudible] pilots.
Yeah, it's true distractions.
I have 13 string extractions. Okay.
13 for 13. Yes. Lucky 13. I know,
that's what my dad said. He had 13,
1300 bombing hours, flight hours,
but he also had 13 months in the POW
and he was also shot down on Friday the
13th.
April 13th. April, April 13th. Uh,
no superstition here on lunch. Yes.
Alright. Continuing on a few
days before thanksgiving.
S T Virginia is one zero
Childress announced that an
operation ordered come down
from the s three.
The team had a mission in the
western section of the DMZ.
And then I'm going to fast
forward a little bit here to uh,
a guy named McGovern quiet
spoken McGovern, gave him
a rye half smile and said,
we can't have that. You need to have
a car. 15 for your first mission.
Follow me. The duo walked
over to McGovern's room.
He opened his locker and
pulled out a clean car,
15 and handed it til the Tourneau.
This is a special car. 15 he said,
according to official army records,
this car 15 was written off as a combat
loss at fob three in case on meaning as
far as the army's concerned,
this weapon doesn't exist someday after
successful tour of duty in Vietnam.
If you're so inclined,
you can take this baby home with
you because it doesn't exist.
But as you can see it does and it's
a sweet weapon. It never failed me.
And I know that since you're a weapons
man, you'll take good care of it.
Up to this point, Latino would use
an m 16 for all of his training.
Now with his car, 15 he was
ready to take on the world.
True. It was a mean weapon.
You see it in that picture? Yeah.
Yeah. Book has the picture of it. Yeah.
The uh,
[inaudible]
and just Joe's rocking
those 20 round mags. I,
every time I see those pictures of you
guys with those 20 round Mags, I just,
I just, we carry, I carry it.
The five of them stuffed
the canteen covers.
We didn't carry food per se. All my food,
I had
zippers sowed into my sleeves up on my
shoulders left and right and I would roll
up dry dehydrated rice with electrical
tape instead of one full ration.
I took one full ration of food and cut
it into five different days from maximum
output. And we only ate once
a day and we just put, uh,
we only had four quarts of water cause
we didn't want to carry any more weight
or any more, anything
else. But ammunition,
we carried all ammunition grenades,
m 79 shells cause we carried
sawed-off m 70 nines.
And so w that's all we carried was
ammunition because when we go in,
that's our supply. There's no
re supply. It's all up to us.
And many a time we came back with nothing
and had to resupply ourselves because
we got down to the last bullet
many times
25. What was your low, do you
know what your load outweighed?
Yes.
My web gear with all the clips and
everything in it and all the water,
all that weighed 75 pounds. My red
sack, because I carried the radio,
the PRC 25 see for claymores,
a blasting caps, all
everything that you needed, uh,
an extra antenna, all that stuff
inside. Was there another 75 pounds?
I weighed 135 I carried
150 pounds in the field.
Yeah, that's crazy. That's, that's crazy.
But that was everybody's load. The
Indian [inaudible] are mercenaries.
They carried probably 130 pounds and
they probably didn't weigh more than 120.
please. Um,
[inaudible]
continuing on the opportunity arrived on
Thanksgiving Day 1968 after the weather
cleared at the quad tri
launch site quoting tri,
is that right? According to
Tree Quang Tree launch site,
SD Virginia boarded the king bees and
headed west of the target area with three
American and four south Vietnamese team
members lap the 17 year old hardcore
point man who had run many
missions hone, is that right? Yes.
Home. The Interpreter Cho,
the m 79 operator and con cowboy,
don't who had fought valiantly besides
Lynne m black jr with s t Alabama as the
second Sikorsky churned
westward, the 135 pounds,
but turno went through a mental
checklist of everything he was carrying
McGovern's car 15 the PRC 25
FM radio, an extra battery for it.
Assad off m 79 m 79 grenade launcher at
22 caliber high standard pistol with a
silencer, ammunition for all weapons,
hand-grenades gas, mass smoke grenades,
a camera, and five special
bags of dehydrated rice.
He quickly realized he was carrying
more than a hundred pounds of gear.
His inner thoughts were jarred when the
door gunner test fired his 30 caliber
machine gun without announcing
his intention to anyone
with a within a matter of
seconds,
the king be cut power and began a
tight downward spiral into the LZ were
children. The lieutenant hone
and lap were already waiting.
The dizzying downward spiral ended as the
pilot rev the engine and landed on the
LZ.
Cho exited the age 34 with the Terrano
and cowboy following him into the
Woodbine connecting with the
remaining members of the team.
The king be lifted off and the LZ
quickly cleared the target area.
Okay.
And then there was absolute silence.
So there's your first, your
first mission insert right there.
My first answer,
you talked about having pucker time
and I'm not knowing what
the heck we're doing,
but we just dropped out
of the sky nowhere. Uh,
and I mean it was adrenaline rush,
but you know,
I'd been roping tigers and rhinos and
I'd be riding bulls and Bronx and you
know, it, it just, it just came to
me, you know, but it, but it was,
I mean I'm here all my training all
that time over a year and I'm here.
This is it. This is the day. Yeah.
Now you question whether you're going
to stand up to it cause you know,
the enemy's there, we didn't
go there for cause it wasn't,
we went there because there was a trail
that needed to be followed and find out
who was running that trail. The, uh,
the door gunner test firing.
That 30 cow is a good wake up
call the library cause you're,
I'm sitting in the door and it's
right over my head, MCAT and the,
and not only that,
our king bees were so stripped that they
were so light compared to the regular h
34 marine ships they could out fly him
in height and we could get up and over
any of those mountains in those
high ranges and stuff. And,
but they dripped oil and they had oil
going down your neck all the time.
And then when he shot that 30 cal over
the top of the hot brass hit me in the
neck. I'm going, holy cry buddy.
You know, scared the crap out of me.
I almost jumped out and I led, uh,
back to the [inaudible]. The
book,
the audio contrast was starting startling
as Latino sense is adjusted to the
quiet. He scoped out the LZ, which was
in a deep valley between jungled covered
mountains, gradually sounds of the
jungle resurfaced. Birds Chirping,
bugs humming. After 10 minutes,
Childress signaled the Chernow to
radio Covey with the team. Okay.
The insertion was successful. No enemy
activity evident. Children's move,
the team toward the first mountain
movement was slowed by tall elephant grass
and the only communication between
the team members was hand signals.
The team moved in 10 minute intervals,
stopping every 10 minutes to listen
to what was going on around it.
After more than an hour,
the team finally emerged from the
elephant grass as it continued to climb.
The first mountain Laterno
was on hyper alert.
His heart pounding hard whether sitting
in alarm rest period or moving up the
mountain near the top of the mountain
lap pointed out in observation platform
that had been cut to the jungle high
off the ground. From that platform,
anyone could observe the LZ and the
valley where the team was inserted as well
as the other open areas that could
be used for landing helicopters.
Had a trail watcher been
sitting on the platform.
When s t Virginia flew into the LZ. If so,
where was he headed and when
would the NVA hit the team?
Late in the day,
the team finally reached the top of
the mountain and found a wide well-used
trail. Latino's first thought was,
how could anyone be out
here in the middle of this,
in the middle of nowhere in
this thick jungle. Regardless,
the team set up it's night perimeter
far above the trail where it could see
anyone moving while remaining
camouflage and out of sight.
At last light children's made the
final Camo check with Covey as the team
settled in for its first night in the
jungle. It was an uneventful night.
Children's did a midnight
Camo check with Hillsborough,
the night command aircraft that flew
high above the Ho Chi Minh trail and the
DMZ and checked in with Covey in the
early morning after the team ate breakfast
and shifts children's directed lap to
move parallel to the trail with cowboy as
the tail gunner in the line of margin
and Latino walking in front of Cowboy,
the team moved slowly in less than 10
minute intervals before taking breaks to
listen to the surrounding sounds.
They did this because moving next to
the trail was fraught with inherit
risks.
So there's your first
night out in the jungle.
Yeah, relatively mellow. It was,
but the mosquitoes were huge and
we wore combats around our heads.
We actually use those for tourniquets is
more as we can pull them down over our
ears and face. Got It.
And pick those mosquitoes out the next
day cause they were like cranes and I
mean then you have to realize too,
that's the first meal for an
entire day with a hundred days,
a hundred degree weather
and only one quarter water,
a sip in the morning, a sip at noon,
a little bit for the dehydrated
rice at night and a sip this,
wash it down with them. There's
one court gone for the day.
You couldn't allow yourself to drink
ever except on those intervals.
And you didn't, you didn't, did
you guys plan to resupply water?
Like did you guys look the maps and see
Nancy Rivers or anything? No streams,
no nothing. So you planned one cord a day.
One a day we figured out is not healthy.
I know you're, I know you're a trainer,
but that's what we had to allow ourselves
because of the weight, you know,
a gallon of water, 7.5 it is.
So we had to judge our weight
versus ammunition and we,
that's what we trained ourselves
to do. And not only that,
we also took pills so that we wouldn't
go to the bathroom either because they
could smell you on smelling American.
That's why we had to eat rice
and eat everything they ate.
Otherwise they'd smell you, you know,
MRIs and, and can't see rations,
all that stuff.
They could smell that for miles and they
had trackers out there and you had to
watch for those, which I
think you'll get to, but
just that water rations what you have.
I trained myself for a year to do that.
I did that all the time cause we
figured we'd be out in the six day,
we'd come out in the six days, so
we'd have no water on the last day,
but we could survive the five days.
Do you ever take any heat casualties
guys that went down from lack of water?
Actually never did. That's
amazing. Never did in the desert.
We would even at training guys,
we'd have guys go down like on a,
on a two day operation. I'd have
guys go down from lack of water.
I've had guys go down and
training and you state side,
but I've never had any,
our guys were, we were,
I'm just going to say we were tough when
the gender is a little different than
the desert too. Yeah, and
because you're got shade,
you're triple canopy, so you actually
are got shade under over the top of you.
You're not in open areas. You
never go into an open area.
You always follow the canopy,
but you have to move slowly
because it's so darn thick.
So it takes time and you have the tail.
Gunner's job is to cover the
trail. Try to put, if you,
everybody walks in everybody's
footprint. If you try,
that's what you're supposed to do.
Everybody has an area to cover.
One guy turns to the right and the
other guy turns to the left point.
Man covers the one 80 in front tail
gunner because of the one 80 and back.
And we trained like that.
We don't turn our backs and look
at what the other guy's doing.
We only concentrate on our area and keep
that area clean unless we have to move
in that direction.
Then we all turn that way
and move it a precision.
It's a precision movement
that we practice.
We train like that every
time we were back in camp,
we train how to move.
That's why our Virginia and Archie,
Idaho or survivable teams besides the
having the luck of the gods with us,
you know,
sometimes you gotta make your own
luck a little bit through. We,
we talk about that all the time.
Like we would train all the time.
I mean we'd patrol around the compound,
rehearse, rehearse, we'd Rehearse,
get this. It always shocks. People are
just getting in and out of the trucks.
Like, you know, we'd have a big, a big
a giant truck to transport troops in,
but we do raids with those things and
we'd practice getting out, you know,
like okay. Cause if this takes you
seven seconds, if you're in a firefight,
I mean Stephan sexist of law a long time
to be trying to get out of a truck that
people are launching grenades at,
you know, and so we'd practice that.
We could do it quickly, do it
at night, do it in the dark,
do it with your gear on, you
know, reverse order. Do it again.
And that's what we do. So that we'd be,
you know, ready for those situations.
The same thing, we actually
working out of [inaudible] before we
had a island called monkey mountain.
Uh,
and we'd go over there and we set up a
course to walk from one side to the other
and that's how we would drain so that we,
we could continually
upgrade how we walked.
And you guys didn't, I've
talked to tilt about this.
You guys didn't bring mosquito nets
in the field to wear over your head.
Never. That would be what
we had was what they call,
believe it or not, they had mosquito
repellent. That was US army issue.
But we also had max factor
that did the makeup.
Okay. And what's that all about?
The grease paint. Camouflage.
Paint color paint. Yeah.
And what Wade would do is take the
repellent and mix it in our palms,
scored into our palms and put the grease
pain in our palms and then put the
paint over our face for it to cover our
highlights. So there's no reflections.
And besides that I used
electrical tape and wrapped up my,
my trousers at the bottom
around my, my boots.
So to keep the leaches out
but also that closed off.
And then I also did that around the
risks of my arms. And then we wore,
we,
our car fifteens were so hot that we had
to wear gloves with a few fingers cut
out of them. We looked
like Michael Jackson
way before his time and wish she had
told him about that grease paint idea.
I liked that, but you didn't know that.
I didn't know. See, I learned something.
There you go. A little
late. A little late. Thanks.
So [inaudible] mosquito repellent and
that grease paint mixed together made a
very gooey mess, but it would
keep them off of your face, you know?
And then when you are at night
when they were at their worst,
you could pull that corvette
down and then you know,
keep 'em Outta your ears and they would
stay off your face because they didn't
want anything to do with it.
And we always carry just a little extra
with us to keep it going, you know,
because being out there for five
days, you know the most that most,
I mean most of the time we get shot
out in a day, two days, three days.
But I had the luck of having
several five and seven day missions.
I, I was able to stay out a long time.
As our teams progressed
further and deeper,
they didn't think we'd go that far,
but we went deeper than
anybody could ever go.
We got down to some of our missions and
layoffs with one minute on time with the
King B.
Okay.
There was no bringing us out. Once
they dropped us on the ground,
it was over with.
They had to go back and get fuel for
no 10 minutes station time just to your
left and to add to. But they
weren't expecting us that far.
We could get right into
all catch him off guard.
[inaudible]
all right.
Going back to the book as s Virginia
moved up the second mountain cowboy and
Latino began to hear women's
voices off the trail.
Yeah.
Cowboy Orange Laterno to go explore the
sounds. Letourneau shook his head, no,
indicating they had to stay with the team.
Cowboy who spoke broken English repeated
the suggestion adding it could be a
small NVA village. We could
kill everyone and make
the NVA Boku angry.
We want to let them know we can hurt them
the same way they attack our camps and
villages,
but turnover again declined and gave
him the hand signal to plant some m 14
anti-personnel mines on the trail behind
them in case the NVA soldiers were
trailing them. As a team moved on,
Latino planted a few more toe poppers
and mark their locations on his map for
after covering them expertly.
He laid down some powdered mustard gas
on the ground for any tracker dogs that
might follow their trail. The mustard
gas was leftover from world war one.
How it landed. It flew by,
remained a mystery to Latino.
The good news was that it still worked.
The fact that it was the
fact was confirmed during
the next break when the team
heard a dog howl in anguish after
snorting some of the old mustard gassed.
Maybe it didn't work that well because
a few minutes later the dog was back on
the team's trail. Cowboy told the Turno
to use his pistol to kill the dog.
Latino's mind flashback to special forces
training group born instructors had
said the same thing,
but turnip pulled out.
The 22 quietly moved back down the trail,
took off as rock rucksack and moved a
few more feet before lying down on the
ground facing the trail.
The dog never realized the Turner was
there when the dog was about 10 feet away.
Letourneau fired one shot.
It struck the dog between the
eyes killing him instantly.
The canine dropped in his tracks out
of Latino's view on aware of what had
happened. The dog's handler moved up
the trail. He got near the dead dog.
When he got near the deck dog,
he stepped on a toe popper.
Letourneau in cowboy heard the
NVA screaming in pain and anguish.
They left him behind figuring he would
die shortly the team moved further up the
mountain with Latino and cowboy
providing rear security again,
Latino and cowboy heard women's
voices below them again.
Cowboy urged the turtle to go downhill
and attack the encampment and again
Latino declined. That's a,
that's so these guys are on you
obviously at this point when,
when you are, you guys are still
heading up the mountain because, but,
but do you think you can get away
from them and what is your point?
What is your, what is your, what are
you trying to accomplish at this point?
At this point we're trying to get away
from the tracker but I've managed to take
care of the chapter but we don't
know how many people are there.
We keep hearing the voices
of women's voices below us.
Cowboy keeps wanting me to go down there
with him trying to confuse the whole
situation cause he wants to kill him
cause he says it'll make them mad.
Then they'll come after us and
we can really get into it. Well,
cowboy just got off a mission on October
5th which is in the book where they
decimated a 10,000 man
division of all things.
Eight and a half hours. They took down
85% of them with an eight man team.
Incredible. But it's true and he,
they stacked bodies up for sandbags.
That's how many they were killing so fast.
But he was insistent.
But I told him we can't do that because
I can't split the team. I have to do it.
My one zero says I'm just a one two I'm,
I'm low man on the totem
pole here, you know,
and there's even a lieutenant with us,
but he's, he's the one one, he's below.
He's actually below my sergeant
because there's no rank in song.
That was one of the things that always
took me aback was there was no rankings
and song. We didn't carry rank, we didn't
wear rank. It was whoever was there.
The longest that lived the longest was
the 10 head man. These the ones zero,
whoever lived the longest was the one
zero. And that's how it went down.
And then when that one zero was killed,
the one one took over usually took over
the team from there on until he was
killed. And then the next one,
the one two would take over.
He would cause he'd stepped up to the
one one position and that's how our,
we progressed with our teams
because everybody was killed one as,
as it as we went along.
We were just lucky.
But I did lose my one
zero Gunther Wall and uh,
of course children's went home and he
was lost to an automobile accident.
And so it's just, you know, but
that's how well they progressing.
And at this point, this is your
first mission you got. It's like,
um, I'm trying to do
everything right. Yeah.
And you're getting the full
benefit on your first mission.
You've got the dog track and you,
you've got the, the NVA camp down below.
You've got the women's voices, you've
got the tracker coming up behind the dog.
I mean it's, he's hitting
the tow popper. This is like,
and we know getting everything, everything
you were hoping for. Here it is.
Here it is.
And we know the is there because the
jungle because their families are there.
So we know of course we
are on, we're thinking too.
Maybe they there the tracking,
there's families too, you know,
because they would hire trackers.
They tell the trackers. You either
track for us, we'll kill you.
And so they have no choices but because
they're just indulge out there living,
trying to survive.
So you're trying to get up the mountain
and get away from the track or was it
possible to shake the trackers?
Was it possible to like actually
lose them sometimes? Sometimes.
Uh, or did you feel like once
the trackers were on you,
you were pretty much
headed into your extract?
Exactly. Exactly. Because they were,
they were communicating in some way of
fashion and let the NBA know we fought
regular Jews. We never shot, fought the
Vietcong that the Vic called the VC. We,
we, we actually fought uniformed, uh,
MVA and uh,
the regular army that
the north Vietnamese had.
But we needed to get off of the keep off
the trail and keep going the cause we
needed to find out where
this trail was going.
This was our mission to try to
figure out where this trail went.
It we did accomplish it in the, in the
end because I went on a second mission,
which is later in the book and uh,
I found actually went into north Vietnam
and with inserted on Christmas of 68 in
north Vietnam on the
same trail but higher up.
And that's a whole different
story there. But [inaudible]
well, going back to
this story, here we go.
By the time Letourneau completed
his last radio call to Covey,
the team was involved in darkness and
team members began to set up a perimeter
for the night. Dawn broke
without any enemy activity.
When Covey flew over
the team in the morning,
he warn childrens that a
team was being extracted,
extracted under heavy fire and another
was being inserted into a top priority.
Target. Sit tight was the
last instruction from Covey.
St Virginia didn't move from its quiet
spot alongside the mountain during lunch
hour. The member,
each member ate in shifts and Latino
went out to inspect the claim.
More minds the team had deployed to
ensure the NVA hadn't turned the deadly
explosive devices around
to face toward them.
When he completed his inspection,
Latino found a log to sit behind.
The NVA would actually do that.
They'd crawl up to your perimeter
and turn your claim on triple canopy.
You don't, you could
pass him up within two feet of you.
They could be two feet away from
me and you wouldn't know it.
That's how thick the jungle
is and you would see a foot,
you know, you think combat,
you might see a foot and you shoot
the foot as long as you shot the foot,
you know, he was down. He wouldn't
go to survive. They had no hospitals,
you know, see that. You could count
that as a, as a kill, but you know,
but you can see, you just had to
mow down the jungle, open it up.
Guess where they're at.
The green tracers coming out
gave you a clue. Yeah. Yeah.
Just shocking to me that they,
they would crawl up and try
and turn around your claymore
mines so that when you
attack, when they attacked you, then
you clock off your claymores and boom,
you're actually claimed
warring yourself. Later on.
The CIA gave us a piece of equipment that
I carried that had a little thread out
of a box and you could wrap
that whole thread around your,
at your encampment or where you were a
always is right at the moment and put it
in your ear and if that thread was broke,
it would sound a buzzing noise in your
ear and you knew somebody came through.
It could have been an animal,
but you knew somebody came through your
perimeter and you just had to put it in
front of all your claymores
and then to stop it,
you just lit a match and burnt it.
[inaudible] use it the next day,
the next time. But once I had that,
my by perimeters were
always covered after that.
Going back to the book
later in the afternoon,
children's signaled the team to pull in
their claim or minds and prepare to move
out. Due to the combined weight of his
rucksack and web gear. We'll turn him,
moved to his knees and slung his rucksack
on his back just as it landed on his
back.
AK 47 his open fire Laterno was
slammed to the ground face first.
The impact so severe he thought he had
broken his nose, startled the Turno,
jumped up with his car.
15 pointing toward the AK 47 gunfire
that was near the front of the team.
Surprised that there was no NVA near him.
Latino removed the rucksack to discover
that for AK 47 rounds had ripped through
the 23 pound PRC 25 he reached into an
especially especially tailored pocket on
his fatigues shirt, which was
sewn with vertical zippers.
One on the left side of the shirt and
one of the right side between the top and
bottom of the pockets of the shirt and
pulled out his URC 10 emergency radio and
broadcast a general alert
for any aircraft in the area.
S T Virginia was declaring
a prairie fire emergency.
Yeah.
So this is like your
first fire from the enemy.
You could shop the radio for four
rounds in the radio. Knock down.
Yeah. I didn't know nothing. All I
knew in my button nose was busted.
I thought it was anyway,
and then I'm going and I'm having
to think what am I supposed to do?
And I was my first reaction. Meanwhile,
my one zero children's was mad
as hell at me because he says,
bring me that damn radio. I said that
her tinning could do crap for us.
He said, I said, it ain't working.
I think it's shot up. And I said,
it don't work. There's no signal.
And so I brought it to him.
Well, needless to say,
I was standing up when I brought it to
him and he's laying on the ground and he
grabs me. He says, can't
you just get down? Well,
the AK 47 rounds are hitting all over
us. We're in the middle of a firefight.
Art Work, returning fire me.
I'm still standing there in shock
and he pulls me to the ground,
saves my life, and he says,
he looks at the radio real quick and
he goes, the intent has been shot off.
That was the fifth round that went
through a breach between my red sac and my
web gear and pulled out my spare antenna
and screwed it on. And we had Camo,
maybe it was good to go air
condition and we just then,
uh,
Pat Watkins is flying over
our copywriter and he called,
we, he assessed what was going on.
He could see it from where his location
was in the air and he could see,
he could see we were taking massive
amounts of fire and he called for an
extraction from Kong tree and they,
they brought the king bees in to
get us and we had to, you know,
yeah, yeah. The, the uh, once
he got that, once he got,
once he got the radio back from you and
it started working children's screams
into the radio, we need an x fill now
and declaring prairie fire emergency.
Is anyone out there? We did a
second or two. There was a response.
Calm down Childress, I realize
you're under fire. Set a Kovi rider.
Just at that moment,
several AK 47 is opened up
from the woodline near the
log where Latino had been
unceremoniously slammed onto his face,
lap and cowboy. He returned fire.
Covey continued.
We heard your team declare a prairie
fire emergency on the guard frequency and
I've rallied the cavalry. What's your
mark? Do you have an LLC in site?
Before children's said a word of the
radio, he turned to Latino and said, see,
it works. Supposedly we'd
left it for the NVA. Never.
I say never ever leave a radio
behind. As if to emphasize that point,
the NVA open fire again as a lab took
as that began looking for an LZ wall,
moving the team down the hill, away
from the most concentrated NVA gunfire,
cutting lectern, no slack.
Children's roared. Tell Covey.
We'll give them a fixed in five minutes.
We'll probably need
strings to get outta here.
I doubt we can make it into the valley
where Kim B King B can pick us up without
missing a beat.
Latino who for the first time felt
for burning stings in his back,
repeated those words to Covey while he
and cowboy providing cover fire as the
tail element of the team.
Then Latino nodded a cowboy who ignited
several claymore minds that the team had
set out on this perimeter.
Those mines only slowed the NVA for a
few seconds before the dust and debris
from the blast settled.
The NVA soldiers were moving through it
toward cowboy and Latino without saying
a word. The two men took turns firing
at the enemy while moving down the hill,
rotating around each other. Cowboy
would fire several bursts from his car.
15 and then reload.
As you reloaded Latina would open fire
providing cover covering fire for the
team. The classic covering moves scenario?
Yes. Just the way we drill
it. That's right. Oh yeah,
and it just came natural.
Believe it or not,
it just came natural. What
part of it just came natural?
Just load and fire and fire and move.
Load and fire move load
and fire and it just, we,
we had to get in the team
came together, our firepower.
You can only imagine what a full team
of firepower with all car fifteens and m
70 nines and Claymore mines going off.
They knew they had a battle but
they'd were overpowering us.
Yeah and it's,
I talked about this with tilt as well,
like the determination of of them
where you think of the insurgence,
insurgent army, you know their
rule is like, hey we don't,
we don't need to fight. We don't
need to win this firefight.
We don't need to win this battle because
we're going to be here for a long time.
We can wait.
We will fight when we want to fight and
it's the way that they attacked you guys
and lot took so many losses but continued
to press and continue to press like
their, their fighting spirit.
Hi. Well let me give
you a backdrop on that.
Maybe tilt hasn't even got to that.
After the war is over with and history
starts evolving in the books and people
start asking questions.
We find out that they've got
40,000 troops hunting this down,
hunting saugers down
and there's a huge bounty on us.
We heard hundred thousand $200,000 to
kill an American on a song team and had a
kill an American award.
If they kill somebody.
They got the award and the bonus and
their instant heroes and who neu forever.
It meant everything to
them to kill us and they I,
they put 40,000 troops designated that
we had tied up because they wanted to
kill us cause we did so much
damage to them. Go ahead.
Speaking of damage, during
one short Lall cowboy, again,
plan to claim or mine in the direction
of the advancing NVA and Latino dugout,
another claim or from his rucksack and
placed a ten second delay fuse in it.
When the NVA, again, advanced cowboy
ignited his Clayborne mind claim more.
When the NBA moved again toward the team.
Latino ignited his fuse and ran down the
hill with cowboy to catch up to their
team before they reached the team to be
40 anti-personnel rockets slammed into
the trees above them,
showering them with shrapnel.
A few more exploded as Latino and cowboy
moved down the hill the ten second then
the ten second fuse ignited
in another claim war.
It brought it bought precious time for
the gun and run team of Latino and cowboy
to cover ground and catch up with
the remainder of St Virginia.
Would you guys drill pulling out those
claymores were the ten second fuse and
hooking them up and setting
them up. I mean, you know,
it takes like a little
bit of time to do that.
Did you guys have them pre rigged where
you could just stick them in the ground?
How did you guys do that?
We did. We had him pre-reqs.
Everybody says, well,
you can't have your blasting
caps with you. You're just,
they hit the black sketch is going
to blow you to smithereens. Yeah.
But those precious seconds would be,
and I had mine in my red Sag
Pre-req. There you go. Yeah.
With us with Bubba had his precut so
we had to five seconds, 10 seconds,
and in longer than you had the actual
cracker itself with the full standard
court that you could blow, that
would give you more distance.
How long was that
course? 50 feet. 50 feet.
So you could put the claymore down on a
tree and pulled back and then you hit it
handheld. Or as we did that one mission,
we were using the five
seconds that bubba put in,
but they were pre cut and
we had them ready to go.
So he just put the fuse in and pull
it and then stick it in the ground.
You're the little steaks,
the standard Gregg jam it in the
ground and you're good. Yeah.
So you're setting those
things up in like 10 seconds.
So she always had to make sure they
were pointed the right way. Yes, indeed.
Point towards the enemy, towards
the enemy. Read the back.
Uh, continue on as Childers called an
airstrikes Latino reflected on house.
Surreal. This firefight had been.
It wasn't like anything he'd witnessed
on television or oriented in any movie.
Instead of men charging each other
and killing each other in plain sight.
Here in triple canopy jungle,
he observed green tracers from AK 47 his
first or at the most an enemy hand or
foot,
and somehow the NVA found firing lanes
where they could launch shoulder held B
40 anti-personnel rockets that slammed
above and around them as they raced down
the hill for their lives.
Again, the [inaudible],
the voices of the special forces
instructors echoed in his mind.
They had told the young aspiring Green
Berets at Fort Bragg that the NBA was a
tough, resilient opponent.
Many had fought against the Japanese
during World War II and against the French
driving them from Vietnam.
In 1954 after the battle of
den BN Pew in North Vietnam,
the sounds of king bees in the distance
and the crashing funder of beef 40
rocket slamming into trees above his head,
shook Latino out of his moment of
introspection and turned his own divided
attention to a crescendo of
AK 47 fire from the enemy.
S T responded with
volley after volley of full
and semiautomatic gunfire
while the Toronto and Cho
fired several m 79 rounds toward the
densest section of the jungle where the AK
47 gunfire was emanating.
Okay.
Through the gunfire, someone
popped a smoke grenade,
which brought the king bees closer to
our t Virginia's location in the jungle
over the din of gunfire,
children's and cowboy told everyone to
put their Swiss seats on and prepare for
an extraction. In short order,
a King Bee was hovering over St Virginia
more than 125 feet above the jungle
floor.
Latino Cowboy Cho and honed hook hook
their d-rings into the old McGuire rig
that hung from the end
of the ropes. And shortly
we're being lifted out of the jungle.
As the quartet of recon men
was being lifted into the air,
the envy on the NVA unleashed another
salvo of AK 47 gunfire and several
[inaudible] rockets.
Shrapnel from the rockets hit them with
varying degrees of size and velocity.
All of them were wounded.
It was during those explosions that Latino
realized his car 15 and somehow been
caught in a rope above him just far
enough away that he couldn't reach it.
He pulled out his m 79 and launched a
40 millimeter grenade toward the NVA
positions.
Now all he could see for of the enemy
were hundreds of muzzle blast from AK 40
sevens in green tracers,
re green trace arounds,
eerily climbing toward the quartet of
s t Virginia men before he could reload
his m 79 the king B began to
move away from the target area,
surprising him because the men
had not yet cleared the jungle.
Instead of continuing to
climb out of the target,
moving straight up until
the men cleared the jungles.
Triple canopy of trees and vegetation.
The King Bee was moving away from the
target area due to heavy enemy ground
fire.
In recent months at least two king bees
were shot down during string extractions
from hot targets, but these facts
were unknown to Latino at the time.
Shrapnel from the beef 40 rockets split
exploded around Estee Virginia men
stinging them with bits of
hot metal. Further spooking,
the King B crew Latino began to
violently collide with tall jungle trees,
feeling like a metal ball
in a pinball machine.
Latino Karun off several more trees as
at least one more be 40 exploded in the
tree tops again, showering
him with trapped [inaudible].
A tree branch hit Laterno from the side
and turned them upside down in his in
his rope Swiss seat as the rope
began to slip down from his hips,
Latino remembered spider telling him
how a one zero from another team had
recently been shot out of his Swiss
seat during a rope extraction.
Another tree struck Laterno before he was
able to muster a surge of strength and
momentum to reach up and
grab the rope above him as,
as his body finally cleared the tree top.
The only thing between him and certain
death blow on the jungle floor 200 feet
down was the single
piece of rope tied into
the King B. Jeez.
Just another day in sock,
just another day in saga.
And I had 13 of those like that.
Okay.
How did you guys, uh, when you,
when you're getting hit with all that
and you're shooting back hanging from a
string, I mean, that's just
like completely insane that,
that no one died on that, on
that rope, on that extraction.
And you're also spinning.
Well, just the rotation that one comp,
we get knocked around the strings
Benning and the air is flowing past you
and you're having, you know, you're,
you're just trying everything
you do to stick with it.
But that was my first mission. Uh,
later on I've finally realized that I
didn't have a extra d ring on my web gear,
the strap in. That's why I was falling
over backwards. I did that twice.
Then I finally found out
from my good buddy here,
tilt that I was doing it wrong,
but because after my second mission, uh,
children's had left,
but he had not given me that
information out of all of our training,
had not thought about it. He
was extracted on another jobber.
So he didn't see that happen.
It's just, it's, it's unbelievable.
When I, when I read these things,
I just can't, it's just
hard to even fathom the,
the mayhem when you're talking
about just all these B 40 rockets,
which is basically like
an RPG, an older RPG, um,
[inaudible].
It's crazy.
Going back to the book
with one final urgent Pola.
Turner was able to move himself upright
in the Swiss seat as the king bee
continued to climb higher into the sky,
distance could distancing itself from
the fear of exploding be 40 and AK 47
gunfire while gaining airspeed as the
king bee ascended the heavily sweating
Latino Clung to the rope as another
sensation overwhelmed his body chattering
teeth.
Within a matter of minutes that King Bee
had climbed to an altitude of more than
5,000 feet where the
air is thinner and much,
much colder than on the
jungle floor. So much colder.
That Latino's body began shaking violently
from the dipping temperatures as the
king bee continued to climb into the
safety of higher altitude in ordinary
circumstances,
few people would ever think about
freezing to death over Southeast Asia,
but for the men and CNC was just another
hurdle they had to clear as the king be
headed east,
we'll turn to look down on the spots
in the jungle that appeared to be good.
LZs thinking, why don't you lay him there?
But St Virginia's collective
agony continued until the
king bees finally landed
in south Vietnam. By that time,
every member of SD, F, s, t,
Virginia had their circulation
cut off to their legs.
They couldn't stand or walk. All they
could do is unhook from their Swiss seat,
grabbed their stuff and try and get the
circulation going again in their legs
while the door gunner helped
them to get back to the king bee.
When the team returned to
Quang Tri Quang tree clung tree launch
site before heading south to food by
children's, pulled the
Tourneau aside and told him,
take good care of that radio. You're
going to take it on the next mission,
whether you like it or not. Where's he
gonna make you bring the shot up radio?
Yeah, he did. We did. It saved
his life tilts life in the end.
How's that? That Christmas Day,
Michigan. Okay. We had the Intel report.
Was that the same radio you brought
a shot up radio in the field.
I got a hundred miles
to get out of it. Oh,
that's ridiculous. As darkness fell.
The King B's lifted off from crying
tree for free by when the old war boards
landed on fob one landing zone. St
Virginia was greeted by one man,
former s t, Virginia,
one zero John McGovern.
He greeted each of the team members as
they eggs exited the king bees asking
each one, are you okay? After the King
B's departed bathing them in sand,
dust and LZ debris kicked up by the
pro prop. Wash McGovern asked children,
did you hear about Baiter? A
tall children shook his head, no.
What happened November 13th we lost a
King Bee with seven SF troops on it.
We lost the entire King Bee crew.
They were a bunch of straphangers who
volunteered to pill pulling the elder son
mission on the trail,
but an anti aircraft round hit the
king be en route to the target.
It exploded in mid air.
They never had a chance
in silence. McGovern drove the tired,
dirty and hungry team
back to the team room.
As the Vietnamese team members
climbed off, the truck,
McGovern turned to Latino and said,
you know what was really
scary about that mission?
The day before they got shot
down. Me, Lynn Black, Rick Howard,
John Peters, Tim Shaf,
and a few others had volunteered and
we're actually on the king bees suited up,
ready to go. Only to,
we canceled last minute
by bad whiskey X-ray,
which is weather in the AOE
that was too close for comfort.
After a long pars pause Latino, he asked
the Turno, how did it go out there?
I heard you were good on the
radio. You didn't get rattled.
You ain't a cheery no more. You've
joined a small, Unique Club of SF men,
C and c recon men who
went across the fence.
It was nothing like I ever
could have imagined to.
The terminal responded looking toward
the Vietnamese team members. He added,
let me get some chow for the
indigent. You will write about them.
They have ice in their veins. I'm
beat. I'll see you in the morning.
Latino walked through the
white sand to the mess hall,
picked up some fresh sandwiches
and cold sodas for the team.
After lingering with the Vietnamese
team members, Latino return to his room.
Finally taking off his rucksack and web
gear as he started to address Latino,
became aware of pain in his back
where from where the four AK 47 rounds
had slammed him face first into the
ground.
First he peeled off as jungle fatigued
shirt and was amazed to find four bullet
holes in it. Then he took
off his undershirt. Ditto.
Four bullet holes were in.
It lets her know, picked up his
rucksack. Four bullet holes were in it,
both in the front and the back,
something he hadn't realized
during the firefight.
Then he looked in the mirror and solve
for large welts and broken skin up his
spine where the AK 47 rounds had hit
his body after punching through his
rucksack and the PRC 25 only
then did a Latino begin to crump.
Comprehend just how lucky you had been.
Hours earlier in the day when the
NVA shot him in the back four times,
the turnover began to cut away the metal,
the black electrical
tape around his socks,
which he pulled up over his pant
legs. To keep out leeches and bugs.
Then he made a startling discovery when
he pulled his pant leg from the sock and
pulled off his right boot for AK.
47 bullets fell on the ground
in the heat of the battle.
The freshman didn't realize that
after you was shot in the back,
the four 7.62 millimeter NVA rounds had
fallen through his pants and his socks
into his right boot.
He stood in utter amazement staring
at the four rounds on the floor before
picking them up and throwing them
in the sand outside his room,
exhausted Latino, walked
over to the shower room.
The water stung the wounds
in his back. Amazingly,
the four bullets had enough energy
to penetrate his skin, wounding him,
but not enough to get under his skin.
Too tired to treat the four bullet wounds
in his back and trapping the wounds in
his arm. Laterno finished his shower
and went to bed
so that
that was mission number one.
There's a saying that we
came to realize later on,
everybody just look at you and say,
well, that's just another day in saga.
My first mission, I had to run
12 more before it was done.
And when you got done
with it, I mean will you,
will you talking to the other guys?
And they were telling you, hey, yeah,
that's, that's how it is.
Yes. That's how it is.
So he couldn't go in the,
into the bar and go there and this
is what I did. Did you say? Yeah,
I got back. Well,
and don't forget the footnote
on that cause like about what,
four or five days later? The medics? Yeah.
Tell him about the
wounds from the shrapnel.
Of course I had to ignore everything
because otherwise they'd all think I was,
you know, just a looper, you know,
so I just had to suck it up,
not saying nothing and,
but all of a sudden I started getting
these boils on me. They were huge.
So I went to the medic and, and uh,
what's his name?
Majia NGO. Mazzeo says, well, he
says you got shrapnel in your buddy.
That's all. That's all swollen.
It's infecting you. He says,
you're going to have that for quite a
while until we can get every piece out of
here. He says, I don't know
how many holes you got,
but this one here needs attention right
now. And it's huge. And there was a,
my arm, my arm, forearm actually. And uh,
he looked at the other
medic shipping and said,
hold him down. And he
looked at me and said,
don't you look at what I'm doing?
Don't you turn your head? He said,
cause otherwise you're gonna pass out
on me when you see what I'm gonna do.
He said, so don't you look
and shipping you hold him,
hold him down and don't work
or they're going to pass out.
Well what he was doing was taking a
big stick swab in hydrogen peroxide and
burning a hole right
through the, the boil.
And then he took forceps and he pulled
the strings out with the shrapnel on the
end from the beef 40 rockets. Cause
they're all made. And you know, in China,
their Chai coms, you know, and
so they had a lot of string.
That's how they wrapped them. They didn't
mold them in the metal like we did.
And so anyway,
I kept having to go and then
another day I had to go in,
he had to do the back of my head and I
had a couple in my head and then I had a
couple of my back and another under my
arm and I walked around with bandages
until I went out on my next mission.
The witness one of those getting
pulled out and it was gross.
What were you doing? Just wanted
to, you know, Spec to spectate.
He had pulled several out. We kept hearing
about these things. Let me show you.
Oh thanks. They're talking
about TMI. Talk about Puss,
pimple breaker. But Hey, where you're
going to go back into the field anyways.
Yeah. It was like, Hey, it
doesn't matter if it, we'll do it.
We'll do what we can right now. But
exactly. Exact field. Yeah, exactly.
Cause we had another mission lined out
for Christmas of 68 so what was the
optempo like meeting? How
often would you, when you did,
you did your 13 missions,
how long did that take? What,
what time span was that over whatever
one year tour. One year tour.
I had 13 missions and one bright. Yeah,
like, and I, some day we'll talk
about the bright light, I guess.
Why not today? But then if you,
you know, it's a, it's a, uh,
it's not written in the books
because of what it ended up being.
But a bright light in SOG is a volunteer
situation where a team of volunteer to
go in and get another team
out. This kid can't get out.
And we had a lot of those. Or to
try to find a team that disappeared.
We had a lot of teams disappear.
I R t Idaho lane and Owen's
completely disappeared.
They've never been found to this day.
No trace, just completely off the bat.
People have gone into this day and hunt
the government hunts today and can't
find them under good circumstances. Are
these the guys that you took over for?
Yes. Yeah. And uh,
so when I got on the Idahoans transferred
from Virginia to Idaho cause tilt went
home and I became Lynn blacks one-on-one.
Uh, one day he had been gone for
a while up at headquarters and I,
I always protected him cause I'm the
one, one I I protected my one zeros.
I had to know where they were doing all
the time cause you just never knew cause
we had, we had nuns, we had Cambodia,
we had mountain yards, we
had Vietnamese in our camp.
They all fought amongst themselves, let
alone wondering if they're the enemy.
And we also had an entire
team of NVA Choo Hoy's too.
Always been,
they gave up and that was team Cobra
and they were there for a very special
mission that they went on and to get
us prisoners out of a camp that was
located. But we got a call,
Lynn went up to the headquarters
and had been a little while.
So I went up there to
see what was going on.
He's walking back down and says
can we go on a bright light?
I said we're ready. We're packed.
Cause that's just what you did.
If you were asked, you went,
he said we got two pilots down
and we in there, we think
they're alive. We got to go in.
They brought a jolly
green giant in for us,
which is very unusual air force.
I don't know where they really took
us at this point in time in my life.
I, we still don't know. They
have all kinds of records,
but it's very confusing of where we went.
We came in and that jolly when we
circled over the top of the plane,
it was all intact. It was just
sitting there in elephant grass.
No one could figure out why.
So they brought us down and I jumped out.
But when I jumped out,
there was a slight lift in the
plane and in the jolly green.
Uh, and it just came down back
down on me about crushed me.
And then it came back up and then Lynn
jumped out and mar guys jumped out and
each I knew and it was an oh two was a
push pull Sesno engine in the front and
engine in the back. That's where
it had been shot down. Yeah.
We think it was shot down. We don't,
or crashed town [inaudible] however,
we just don't know how it happened.
But what the real deal was is the plane,
whatever happened to it,
was making an emergency landing and he
saw this opening like an LLC and thought
this would be a good place to
at least start the landing.
Even if it went into the jungle,
it would slow it down. Problem was,
as soon as they hit the ground,
there was a bowl and they hit the front
of the bowl with the front engine and
stopped dead like a bird track.
It was a bird. Yeah. And uh,
it stopped it dead, but it bent
the engine around to the right.
And the man in the right seat was
sucked up into the carburetors,
into the lie comb engine. And, uh,
he was in the fins and he just had
his head in his arms sticking out.
Said when I got there on that side,
it said 10 minutes after 10 in the
morning is Rolex watch was cracked,
the Bezel was cracked, and it
stopped the watch at 10 after 10.
And we didn't get there
until about two 30. Well,
don't forget when the chopper's going
down. You're under fire. Yeah. And it's,
we're, we're getting some small arms fire.
And Lynn goes to the pilot side on the,
on the left side and he looked fine,
but we realize that yolk had crushed
his chest and killed him in place.
But it also had him trapped and
we couldn't get either one out.
But at that point in time
that was a trap they'd set.
The jolly green had backed off and we
started taking tremendous amount of of
fire. And I looked across
the inside of the cabinet.
Lynn Lynn looked back at me
and I said, I love you brother.
We're not getting out of this.
And he, he said, no, we're not.
This is it finally got us.
And I looked up and radio the Johnny
Green to come back in and he shook his
head. I could see him plain
as day. He shook his head,
I don't think I can come back. I said,
you better cause I got
an m 79 pointed at you.
I'll take you down with
us. He moved up forward.
By that time, there was
200 NBA surrounding us,
given it everything they got.
And we managed to crawl into that chopper
cause if we got up on the wings and he
scooped us up and I had already called
in tech here cause they already had tech
care ready.
And as we lifted off and got
up about 50 feet and they,
one sped flew right underneath us between
the plane and in the chopper and I,
he looked up at me like this
was smiling and he dropped a WP right
on top of him and there was crispy
critters running everywhere.
And we got out of there and
got back and we walked down,
landed us back at fob four and we walked
down the road back to our hooch and we
just looked at each other
and said another day and saw
time. They're on the ground,
they, they're under fire going in.
They put a perimeter around the aircraft
while Lynn and Doug went in to try to
establish what the
status of the pilots war.
And the firefight was intense
because I remember when I got back,
Doug had just left and I came back to
Nava at the end of October 69 so that
bright light was fresh on Lynn's mind and
we talked about it and I talked to hep
later about that Riley and her going,
this was crazy cause hap Saudi went in
with four and ditch from a RTI to own
that team. And Lynn was like, man, I
don't even know how we got out of there.
So it was one of those real,
another just a really tight one.
But like Doug says,
in a way when you now in retrospect
like had just another day in SOG,
but that wouldn't really stuck.
Yeah,
I just thought that out of all my missions
and if you read the book and where
tilt honors me with a few missions in
his books between across the fence and on
the ground,
that when there was is as tense as it
got and we thought it was over physically
and mentally we gave up.
We thought it was over that
we just weren't going to
get up out of that mess and
get into that shopper than be 40 rockets
were hitting that plate underneath that
jolly green.
We were going up in the air faster than
the chopper could get us up in the air
from the pounding. We were taken
that hadn't been for that span.
We might not have to this day,
we can't find this bad pilot.
We'd have reunions we
go to as bad reunions,
but we still haven't been able to
find that sped pilot that did that.
Cause what he's saying is like when
the John Green's pulling out the,
before he pounded underneath
and the armor plating,
he could sustain it and it w but it would
give the chopper Joel like Lynn Black
Hat on October 5th and this
is what they're experiencing
one October a year later saying,
yeah, yeah, exactly. Yup.
I'm surprised that they take
those B 40 strikes like that.
I mean one lucky shot that hits the tail
rotor or something and it's just game
over. Sure. You know when
we get back on missions,
we'd walk around our King Bees and count
how many bullet holes and how many were
in the blades. We did, there's clean
shots through the blades and then we,
we'd caught 40 50 80 rounds in
king bees when we come back.
And pieces of metal gone that
they had to put tin over.
They use beer cans. Yeah.
Aluminum beer cans. Yeah.
And what about the, um, what
about that operation where you,
we had to go and get the 55 gallon
drum of [inaudible] and pull that one.
Yeah. Okay. We'll go through that.
Somebody would probably
like to read it in the book,
but we'll kind of go through
that. We were trained,
we had a CIA agent come in and trainers
for a brand new explosive detonator.
That was a time device that was shaped
on the top end of the Bung of a 55 gallon
drum as curls. You put a
wrench on it and unscrew it.
You've seen them. And we said,
this is, by the way, this
is a seal type missing.
So you really appreciate this more.
Absolutely. Yeah. When I read about it,
I was like, man, this is a good
seal mission. Yeah. But, oh well.
Well they didn't want to see that.
Let's do that in those days,
Huh? No, they're busy on the coast.
Yeah. They're busy on the coast.
They really were. We under this, I mean,
everything up to that isn't a jungle,
obviously you get to the river boat.
Exactly.
But we actually went into secret, uh,
lock up, uh, couldn't talk to anybody.
Nobody could come in and talk to us.
And we went through these exercises
and training. We actually,
uh, loaded up for it and
they took us out to the,
and took us to a Kang tree and
we launched out of there and uh,
went into layoffs into this
huge river that they had,
but we had to stay away from it.
We had to actually hike in
for two days to get to it.
And when we got there and down
the hill and to the river,
it was night on the second
end of the second day.
And then Gunther was my one
zero and I was as one one.
There was no one, one, two and uh,
he was an ex marine and he
was an east six. And uh,
he was my one Siro he'd
been around a while and uh,
he says, okay, go in and get that drum.
And I says, well, you're the marine,
you're navy. Why should I
go it? Cause you're the one,
you're the, you're the one one
the European IFC and I'm an six.
So that's how it's going down.
And don't forget before you get there,
they hiked through jungle for two days
and two nights right to meet the CIA.
I forgot that. Who gave them the
specialized chart where he come from?
He had Chinese with him and he said,
I will meet you out there to give you
this device because I can't trust anybody
to have this device in case you're
caught between now and then. And I said,
there's no way we're going to find you
out there. This is impossible. He says,
don't you worry about it, you get to
this coordinate and I will, I will
find you. That's impressive. And he did.
We got that coordinate and we waited
and we waited and next thing we know he
come right out of the jungle and there
he was. We were going to kill him.
We thought was NBA. Yeah,
of course. Chinese with
Zola. Nautilus was his name, if you
pronounce it right, I probably do.
I can't pronounce it right,
and spelling. It was,
he actually was a renegade CIA agent.
He was a desk jockey that wanted to
prove that he could be an infield agent.
As the story finally went that we didn't
learn about this until what about 12
years ago and we asked
did you meet him later?
No, no, no, no, no one knows where
he went or what happened to him.
We met another CIA we needed,
that was actually a counterpart to a
Russian KGB agent that when they di rush a
deep,
finally admitted and declassified the
Vietnam War and admitted they had 3000
Russians helping the, the NBA,
and they had a reunion and they
did an actual video of the reunion,
admitting that they had worked with the
NVA and the Chinese and helping the,
the NVA go up and down
the Holcim in trail. Well,
this Zola NAACOS had figured this
out and got ahold of this device.
And
how we learned about it was this CIA
agent had gone there and help declassify
all the records of special
ops stuff that was, they were,
they had located. And the hole here,
they found my name in the
KGB at files in Moscow twice.
My code name and my real name
and the missions that I ran.
They did that twice. And they
found Lynn because we bumped into,
uh, what we,
I thought was a Mexican
Spanish speaking person,
speaking broken English. And
I'm from California, right.
And I go back to my old
days and I told Lynn,
I said this, this guy's
a Mexican gotta be,
what the Hell is he doing out here?
And he's talking to us on the radio,
he's got our frequency. And Glen
says, give me that football on it.
So he goes back and forth with him and
he says, you got to move out of the area.
And he says, I'm not going to move
out of the area. I'm here to stay.
Here's my coordinates. He'd given
a five digit coordinate. No,
what are you going to do? He says,
well, nothing, but you need to move out.
He was trying to save our butts cause
he, he was from Angola, was a Cuban,
stationed in Angola and had been shifted,
loyal Laos and then turned around
and he hated the Vietnamese so much.
He was trying to help us,
but we could see him on the other side
of the river that where we were at on
this particular mission.
And so that mission was in the KGB files
that we had spoke to him and he had
our, and they knew it was RTI Edo
and that we knew it was linen me.
And so they are they at as much,
cause we had spies in Saigon
giving all this information out to,
he had a spy that, that uh,
they finally caught an American,
it was giving all this information
now, but for two missions,
I'm in the KGB files. So
on this oil drum mission,
we get down there after we've been given
the device and night and I go in and I
grab a hold of a drum and of course
they have those little lips on there.
I can pull that drum it in there full
about three quarters because they gotta be
buoyant.
And I bring that fueled drum right
to the side and I'm holding it there.
And Gunther unscrews it,
the bung off and puts the new
one in, screws it up tight.
Now I've got to get that drum back
out into the flow while the flow is
NBA walking it down with bamboo
poles, pushing them around.
So I get it out there, but I can't
get back because here they come.
So I had to go under and hold my breath,
but I can't hold my breath that long.
And this water is ice cold. Right.
But fortunately I was a great
swimmer in my youth and I,
I could, I could handle this,
but I could get my nose just above the
surface blowout and take a breath and go
back under. But cause it's dark
and they went on by me finally.
But I thought for sure they'd
stick me with the one of the Poles.
But they pushed that drum on down in
the few drums that were around me.
And I came back to the edge and
crawled out. But I was so cold,
I could hardly move. I'm
soaking wet of course.
And Guthrie says, come on, we got to go.
And I finally put my gear back on my
rucksack and the radio and my web gear and
everything else back on
and up the hill. We go,
but I'm still just barely making it,
just barely making it. I'm so stiff.
And uh, we crawled out of
there. Took two days to get out.
But that device was set for two
days, but they hadn't gone off yet.
But we finally got extraction orders in
and they came and got us and strung us
out. And when we were
on strings, it went off.
The cubby rider was there
and it was like an atom bomb.
It was a miniature
mushroom. And the shockwave,
even though we were miles away,
came through us on strings and the
choppers and just like this and we're,
we're going like this back and forth and,
and the chopper and the,
and the Covey plane is shaking like this.
And I mean it was like an atomic
bomb just went through us.
What you picture when you see,
and then then everything
became calm and, uh,
mission completed. That's a good one.
That's a real good, that's a good.
So they never knew, never knew. Well,
they didn't know until the Russians knew.
Yeah. But other than that,
they never knew who w and we weren't
allowed to talk or tell anybody in camp
when we got back, they just, what were
you doing? Oh, just another day in song.
And that was what we said,
because we weren't even allowed to tell
anybody what we did because of the CIA
mission that we ran. But we,
everybody had certain things
that they did like that,
but it was the first time it
had ever been accomplished.
What did you notice about the one
zeros that you had from a leadership
perspective that you remember
as like, yeah, this is,
this is the quality,
some of the qualities that they had from
a leadership perspective that you would
follow them. Uh, I was most fortunate.
I think I had great ones. Zeros,
some of them not as
great as others. But, uh,
when you, my first one,
he was my idol because my
first two missions and,
uh, thanksgiving of of
68 and Christmas a 68.
And you can't ever forget
those, you know? And uh,
so fact,
the mission of 68 is where I got the
skip from the bloat up radio that let him
know he was walking into an edge letting
tilt know that he was walking into an
ambush.
And I'm laying on a trail with
the radio on and heard this.
My interpreter comes up and
interprets what's going on.
I managed to get ahold of spider parks.
He just had me going by for a radio
check and I told him what was going on.
He radios to the tilt to turn around
and go back that he had intel and tilts
going. What?
Yeah, it was the first time I've
ever had like a direct Intel report.
Do not go through the northeast.
This is the Christmas Day mission.
We were on top of that knoll
and Lynn and I had talked about,
that was the one quiet area
of probably there's a problem,
but we were talking that spider goes
do not go through the northeast.
We have an Intel report. Do not go there.
I'm the only Intel report
that never happened before
or after on a live mission.
We're on the ground and we
didn't know what the hell it was,
but they were right.
We did and you noticed or we could
extract as it were back in base.
A few days later, him and bubba
connect and it's going like, yeah,
what were you on the ground at Christmas?
And then we found out is that, uh,
he had that Intel report
that was confirmed the one
place we could have gone.
We shouldn't have, our
instincts were right,
but we had a confirmation from the
Intel report and it was just amazing.
You know, he says to this day,
they got out of it and due to
other factors they got out of it,
but just that it saved the team was
walking into an l shape, ambushed,
and they've been
slaughtered. And they were,
they were pushing them that
way with trackers, gunfire
and everything else. And,
uh, so they just, just like you say,
the gods were always with us sometimes.
But, uh, at that very next day,
I'm still on the trail
where we were signed.
That was the trail for my very first
mission. We got into north Vietnam,
into it. We called nickel steel.
And I'd been laying there for four days
through this process. And Gunther was a,
I mean, children's was, uh,
my one zero and we were
taking turns and uh,
it had been defoliated with Agent Orange
and so we had a pretty good view and
all of a sudden I saw
six pointman coming up.
MBA. I'm up there at the trail
behind the log. They're down below.
I give them the signal,
I got six and I can see him and children's
right away, he knows what's going on.
So he's preparing the team to fight
and exfil out of the situation,
but he can't with me up above.
But here comes one of the NVA.
He comes right up to the log and
steps over and steps right on me.
I put my car 15 into his belly and
I pull the trigger all 20 rounds.
I made a big, gapping hold
all the way through him,
threw him over the log and I'm on the run
and I've got the radio and down the
hill we go and here comes 200 in VA
and there point Jason is, and
we're, we're bringing, um,
I'm trying to get TAC air on
the line. I finally do. We're,
we're putting tack here between them
and us and I'm throwing smoke over my
shoulder. Yes. Anything,
anything in the smoke killer.
And finally they bring some
slips in and pull us out and uh,
get us out of there on strings,
on strings again and on the run.
And so the side note to
the whole mission is,
I don't know how many we killed,
but it was not a good day for them,
but that agent orange was
the only time I was ever it.
And right now I've got stage four cancer
from Agent Orange with a limited amount
of time left.
So that's why I'm glad
I'm here to tell them
new stories. Glad you're here to airborne
the um, so how many tours did you do?
Was that w one tour?
I signed up for one,
I volunteered to go into special
forces when I was regular army.
I volunteered regular army, went
through, got special forces,
volunteered Vietnam, volunteered
for CCN and saw og and, and uh,
did one tour and I went back home and uh,
became a weapons instructor for
Special Forces Training Group and uh,
and got out. And so how many years
was the total? Three, three years.
Three years. That was it. And
then what'd you do when you,
when you got out? Uh,
I kind of went back to Rodeo and uh,
training horses and things
like that. And then, uh,
I sorta got calm.
Got Your Pos license? Yeah, I got my
pilots license, fixed wing and rotary.
Where you got home.
How long did it take till kind
of adapt to the civilian life?
It took about a year that,
because I slept with my car, 15.
And then when I was in training group,
I always had all the weapons around me.
I felt safe, but it,
you know, 4th of July.
It was always a hard one with stuff
going on, you don't know. And it,
it took me a while to do,
to calm down and not because I had a
lot of kills and you just have to work
through all that all the time.
And I was pretty good
cause not after that,
uh, period of time, you know,
we'd never talked to each other.
We weren't allowed to talk about
it for 20 years is what I was told.
So I never ever talked to anybody.
I never met anybody until 2000
did you guys, I mean when you, when
you, you guys didn't keep in touch,
you guys didn't write each other or
figuring out each other and I wrote each
other, but he, his family moved.
I only had his mother and father's
address and I lost contact for 25 years.
I moved, he moved, my
parents moved and uh,
so the Camo dropped but we were
down. There was no books. No,
no one, nobody could say anything. What
about other team members? Other guys?
Was there anyone that you kept in
touch with over the next 20 years? No.
So when you were done, you were done.
I was done. Didn't do it. It was over.
Cause I couldn't find anything, anybody
I didn't know anybody to talk to.
So I was just done and
I just let my life just,
I never thought about
it anymore. You know, I,
I knew I did stuff but I
couldn't talk about it.
And I had gotten married and
I told my wife about it, but,
uh, we just thought that we
didn't know where anybody ran.
I didn't know where anybody went to.
And then all of a sudden the internet
came about and I typed in SF one time and
a couple of emails came up,
old ones I typed in and McCluskey got,
he was working as an, uh,
a medivac pilot and uh,
he called me and you see he was on shift
and he saw it and he called me and he
gave me tilts phone
number and I called tilt.
The next day was Easter
Sunday 2000. Yeah. Yeah.
We're going to get ready to go to church.
I have, I hadn't seen
him since 1968 or 69.
And where were you living at the time?
I lived up by you semi national park
in the town called Mariposa. Beautiful.
And you were just down in Oceanside?
Yeah, working at the paper,
the fish wrapper. So I said,
well shoot, you know, uh, I,
I got the phone number and I
called him on Easter Sunday.
He was going out the door to go to
church and I said, you better sit down.
This is the Frenchman
that we've been, we talk
every day now cause we can,
what did you, uh, what'd
you do for a job? So you,
you had to kind of continue to
kind of get it out of your system,
were breaking horses or whatever Rodeo
for another year after you went out
breaking more bones. Uh,
and then you went into construction
business in the construction business
that my father had gone into a private
construction for a particular person and
uh, so at left the uh, license open.
So I just continued the license and he
handed it over to me and I built for
almost 45 years. I'm retired now.
What, where did you guys overlap? What
was the, did you guys overlap in RTI?
Idaho. Is that when you guys overlap?
Well, we are at food. When he came
in, he came with a Bubba. Okay.
And so McGovern got him first before
I were talk to him and I got bubba.
So we're in camp, we're training
together at the firing range.
Then Bob and I were doing our targets
that they're doing theirs. And um,
then when we moved, he was,
he closed out fob one is the last SF
troop there. His recon team closed it,
locked the gate.
By that time Lynn and I were
down in a Denang already,
so we're running missions.
He went down with,
with the RT Virginia with Gunther Walt.
And so they went down random mission,
including the famous oil drum one.
And Lynn and I were doing our thing and
then by April my time and country was
getting close. So Lynn had agreed
to be the come to one zero.
We had a special missing, we're
supposed to go up to [inaudible] pass.
We brought Doug in a Max fort and Barry
and an officer to go with us on that
mission. We trained for the
mission train right up to it.
Went to the launch site on the choppers,
took off and they called us
back and because two aircraft
was shot down over the
target area that day.
And so I was about four or
five days from de Roasting.
We then we went back to camp,
they put up the Marble Mountain.
So we're up there, we have some pictures
from that time there. And then, um,
I walked off of Marco Mountain,
went back up my gear and went home.
So Doug stayed with Idaho. Got It.
So from April at the end of April,
all the way through October 69,
he's with Idaho with willin and they
ran a load of missions and I come back,
he just left base crowded, but Lynn's
there, southern Lynn was the one zero.
So he and I took turns and in
find that sergeant major goes,
is too much experience here,
black, you're outta here.
And then I went back to being a one
zero for another five months and that by
that time he had come home,
but he's in training group.
So technically he got out of the
army after I did, I got out in April.
And you got out in June. July,
September 1st December 1st. Yeah.
And so, uh, I went, my,
I went back to the garden state and then
he went back to California and separate
ways. And we did, we had
the cards in some notes.
I don't think many phone calls and it
just let us back if we had a couple guys.
I had other people I stayed in contact
with and then I just figured he got a job
with a CIA or did something
somewhere else, you know,
and then finally got the phone call
in 2000 and the rest is history.
And how often do you guys link up now?
Every day it's on the phone. Like
it's like you and the Echo Charles,
you know,
and w we, we talk almost every
day and uh, because we can,
we're alive and we try now to spread
the story since we've been declassified.
Like you're helping tremendously
to spread this story,
to let people know that we actually,
there was a secret war going on and we
were actually taking the war to the enemy
because our country had signed a treaty
saying that we would not go into north
Vietnam, Laos and
Cambodia or the DMZ. They,
which we operated in every day.
Right. We weren't stationed here.
We just flew in by helicopters.
People always ask me, well,
how long did you fight
in South Vietnam? I said,
I never fought a day in south Vietnam.
They all, you need to do anything. No,
that's true. Yeah. Right.
It's, what was your reaction?
That stuff started to Kinda come to the
surface and people started talking about
it. Uh, it was a slow,
pretty been a slow process. Uh,
I've got to hold a tilt and then we saw
each other the very first time after all
those years, like he was standing on a
corner when I drove by and picked him up.
Yeah. And we went, yeah, we
went to an air show. And, uh,
we started talking, we had our, uh,
photo albums that we weren't supposed to
have cause no pictures was supposed to
be taken. Look at all the
pictures that are out there.
Good recon men always do
whatever they want. Right.
So w w but it's been a slow, he says,
well we have a reunion now. I really,
we'd have it in Vegas every October
now. And uh, it's been going on what,
45 years? 43 44 years. 44 years worth. I,
I've been there about 18 years now.
Special Operations Association. Yup.
And, uh,
so we go there and see each
other and sit around and drink.
And of course I don't
drink, but you know, we,
everybody drinks and it's a free bar and,
and tell old war stories to each other
and just a couple of lies and stories get
more exaggerated. And,
but we, we have, uh, we,
we have the opposite problem
is we're dying faster than,
than you can. We're, we were
losing about 10 or 12 tops, six,
seven in the very beginning.
Now we're losing over 50 a year and there
weren't that many of us to start with,
but this is a combined
all the support troops,
actual recon troops,
there's probably not but 45 or 50 there
at all at all because we only had what,
450 [inaudible] passenger
you talk to, you know.
And so, uh,
we have this great reunion every year
and I just never miss it because I don't
know who's going to
die, but it's like, uh,
yesterday was our interpreter hepps two
year anniversary of his death and most
everybody's going down with Agent
Orange of some kind of cancer and stuff.
Uh, LDN Bardwell just went
down from an accident. Uh,
he was our two star general, very
proud of him, but at the time he was,
we were both shocked
in Germany was where I didn't, I, my,
my boss would work directly for him,
so I was, I was under his command, but
my, my boss at the time just, you know,
just absolutely loved them and,
and you know, tried to tell me,
try to give me quotes when he'd come
back from a meeting with bars. Well,
he said, Barb old Dan said this,
no old man said that, you know, he,
he was just a [inaudible] my
house not too long before that.
And, and uh, in my train room, I,
I've got trains Lionel and, uh,
he was there and had a great time.
They were roommates for a few months
and we went on R and r together.
I've met his first son, uh, when
he was two months old. Yeah.
And you know, remember story with
Elvin getting shot in the chest. Yeah.
So two days later,
Elden and Doug went to Hawaiian
with their respective wives for R.
And. R. They're there for
five days in Elden met
his son for the first time. His eldest
son Brandt Brandt grant was here.
So you guys must have watched him
cause he was, you know, uh, uh,
a general in the army and he was in the
limelight for sure for a military guy.
And you guys knew the whole time
you're looking at him thinking, Hey,
we'll just call him
specialist fourth class.
Cause that's the way we knew I
could never call him general.
I could never call him barge you.
I called him Elden, you know,
spent four Elvin and he was the same
Elden that we met in 68 is the same outlet
with went to reunion with his last year.
He was there and as we
spend a glory and uh,
know that's the way we respect him.
Like when my son got a wounded and in
Iraq he went and saw this care at the
hospital, picked up for him right away.
They couldn't believe at two star general
walk in for some little girl. Yeah,
some of those best. He's a scout and he
got banged up with a Humvee. Really bad.
But the Elton was, what year
was at, uh, August 20th,
2005 a couple of weeks later.
You were in country then?
I W I didn't while I was in there. Oh,
three Oh four. And you know six. Where,
do you know where it was in Iraq? Yeah,
he was southeast of the Green Zone.
Okay. Yeah. Small world.
What's he doing now?
He's up at doing heavy equipment training
up in a long beach. Him and Bruno,
his faithful companion or they're doing
it and just kicking ass. Take a number.
So pretty soon have all the licenses
in place and if you need any, uh,
heavy equipment work,
give him a call right on.
And a freshman will build a house
for you. Adrian, what about, so you
got, you got, you got married when you
got done. Is that or along the way?
Along the way? Yeah. And
did you have any kids?
I have a son and I have a daughter. I've
got a grandson and two granddaughters.
Very proud of them. I'm
really proud of my son. He,
he has his own company in the
oil business doing really well.
He would pairs all the big
fracking machines. Yeah. Um,
I'm right now, I'm in Texas. I was
in Tennessee when I'm in Texas now.
Now that I've found out
what my medical health is,
I want to try to get my grandson to, uh,
know me before I go. Well,
that's, that's awesome.
He's going to be as proud as he can
be. As proud of you as you are of him.
That's for damn sure. Well, they
made an action figure of me,
so I've left that action figure for him.
And that's the famous picture. Yes.
The famous SOG. Uh, the Frenchmen.
Yes. I've seen it. There's a good review
of it on, on uh, youtube I watched.
Yeah. The,
you can go to youtube and
look up Frenchmen action
figure and it's done really
well by Ryan Peters. Yeah. He
did a really excellent job.
Even made the box and everything
for it. Yeah, no, it looks,
it's pretty awesome. Well, I'll
definitely, I'll definitely post the data.
That picture when, when this goes
up, when this goes out onto the, uh,
on the interwebs, as they say. And
you've got your freshman challenge coin.
I got my freshman challenge
coin. Yeah. It's right here.
The lowest ranking challenge coming
out there makes the general's MBA.
It's a PFC challenge.
It doesn't get much better
than that. Yeah, for sure.
Uh, you got anything else?
I think this is a good place to be and
if you listen to this and you think of
more things you want to say, but
you know, I think this is a good,
good spot to wrap up this one.
So if you've got anything until you got
anything else first. No, the stories.
Um, you know, it's funny
because even we were in base,
we never knew a lot of the details
and so when I put the books together,
talked to other people,
like the oil drums story,
we learned about 40 years later that
Lynn black had done a similar thing with
RTI, Idaho after I left
right in between these guys.
And it's just like a lot of
histories that comes out slowly.
Like Doug said,
was anyone tracking? Was anyone writing
down the history as it was happening?
Was anyone taking the operational
summaries and compiling them somewhere?
They were all destroyed.
That was when I left Fubu by one of my
jobs was to go through and make sure that
all the drums had been note the ashes.
They had burnt all the reports after
action reports were all burnt and then as
we pulled out of every fob and
closed down CCN and CCS and CCC,
we closed them all down.
Everything was destroyed.
There's very few after
action reports with their rs,
just minuscule reports. People
try to put them out on Ebay,
but their fake, there just isn't any
think there are out there. We, we haven't.
There are reports of archives that
were even now began to look into,
but at a recent reunion, a guy
came up to me and said, hey,
you know, if you'd done your books, I got,
I like to talk to you because my job
when we closed cartoon was to destroy all
the records. Yeah, yeah. Lot of valor.
Yeah, we, that's why the upset,
I didn't even receive my purple heart
for that first mission until 11, 11, 11.
Rio had to go back to the paperwork on
it and we had to find years and a lot of
people and, and, uh,
a lot of affidavits and a lot
of this and a lot of that.
And it took six years.
And until Diane Black,
my congresswoman, uh, called me one day.
I was coming back from Arlington,
from burying Gunther Wall and,
and my Virginia team,
Donnie shoe, and, and, um,
Bill Brown, William Brown. And
uh, she calls me on the phone.
I don't even know who she is. She says,
are you Douglas Eternal, the Frenchman?
I said, uh, yes. And she says,
I'm Diane Black Congressman for Tennessee,
for your district, for your district.
And I'm in my limousine right now and
I'm holding a purple heart in my hand.
How do you want it presented? I said,
I want you to pin it on front
of our memorial in Gallatin,
Tennessee. And, uh, she did on 11, 11, 11.
And my guys came and watched.
I had seven of my saugers come
to that and watched tilt came.
Everybody flew in, we were there,
they were there for witness.
And even though we found one to medics,
they had pulled that this string out
from this trapping as an eye witness.
That's, that was a key thing.
We got the CEO to do a letter but took
a while to track it down and put it
together. But we did
cause all the records had
been destroyed, you know, so.
Well this record won't
be destroyed right here.
I promise you that podcast
one eight six one eight six.
There you go. But I would like
to say as a closing thing,
my mom and dad are both
gone. My Dad was a hero.
He gave me everything he had to
give. He was the best father ever.
My mother was the best
mother. I'm proud of my kids,
my daughter and my son. What
they've accomplished in their lives.
I'm proud of my grandkids
and what they do. And uh,
I'm glad that I have
something to leave behind.
And his mom when she, when
she'd learned my mother died,
I got a phone call next day till
your mom's dead bottom of your mom.
Yep. My mom loved every one of them. Bubba
came to La and said,
I need a bunk up for a couple
days. Six and a half months later.
And He'd gone through the LAPD
and six and a half months later,
he even got married and brought
his wife into the house.
My Mom and dad finally
said, enough's enough
for your wedding present.
We're giving you an apartment
date. But any Sauger was welcomed
in my mom and dad's house.
Oh yeah. Well, uh,
that is awesome. And as
you both should know,
any soccer is welcome to come here at
any time and, and share their story.
There's this door to,
this podcast is open. Uh,
this could just become the sod podcast
as far as I'm concerned at this point.
So work on
it. We thank you. Yeah. Appreciate
it too. Thanks for coming back. Yeah.
You've opened up a lot of doors to
people that will hear this history.
Absolutely. And they'd
there. I'm sure there are.
I'm sure you're hearing from
until, I know that you've been,
you've been transferring some of
the messages to me. What's your,
what's the Twitter that you're
actually looking at right now?
Cause you have a couple,
oh, you have John Soggy of SOG chronicles.
Do you know which one it is?
Oh my daughter said there's one is j
Stryker Meyer initial Jane and strike of
mine. I haven't, I've fallen
out of the Twitter thing.
You've admonished me that
season. So Instagram, Instagram,
Instagram is what you're doing a little
bit. Your social media over here.
I'm trying to catch up to you.
I might be slow but I'm slow.
Who been so busy the last few
weeks, um, between work and yes.
Responding to a lot of the
feedback from folks, uh,
off of the up last podcast.
People want to reach out to you. Should
they go through through John Frenchman?
Yeah, they can go, they'd go great
out through with John Or, uh,
they could catch me on train
one 53. The word train one,
the numbers53@hotmail.com.
That's my email.
It says email and then my website is saw
chronicles.com and my emails here and
I'll connect anybody with Doug as the
old fashioned way in Instagram's where
we're still working on that. But my
daughter's got to give me another piece.
She went to Tennessee, so she's
out of town. I'm struggling,
but maybe give me a briefing when we
hang up here. I close out tonight.
That all good. Eh, it's such an
honor to talk to you guys. Frenchmen.
It's an honor to meet you and
a, you're welcome back. Anytime.
I'm glad that I could come and meet you.
And I told you what
happened on the airplane.
I'm sitting next to somebody and
he goes, what are you doing on?
I'm going to go do a podcast
with a guy named Jocko Jocko.
Oh my God. I got him on my feet,
whips out his phone and there you are.
And he says, I got Twitter with him.
I got everything when he's my buddy.
Oh, I mean,
why would I even expect that somebody
would have such a small world?
It really is.
Well, regardless of our service,
we're all part at 1% or less of a,
of our country. [inaudible] that
served a country. Yeah. And in combat,
and I'll tell you the, the, uh,
amount of feedback I've gotten
from when you came on till, I mean,
it's been overwhelming the number
of people that just, you know,
thank you for your service.
They're going to pass the same
thing on to you and you know, um,
you guys should know that America loves
you guys for what you did for this
country.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. Too much. You
too. Airborne, airborne, all the way,
all the way.
And with that,
SOG has left the building.
The Frenchmen and tilt
have departed. Awesome. What an a,
what an honor and a half those guys on.
And I've got to say this
right after we got done,
of course were we did some more
talking and the Frenchman was,
was explaining the fact that when
he would go out on a mission,
every mission he would go out on,
he would square away his footlocker,
make sure everything was
ready to be shipped home
because every time he went out
he figured he would not be coming back.
[inaudible]
real heroes.
And it's awesome to be able to
sit here and talk to those guys and
what a, what an honor
that is. And anyways, um,
you know,
actually one of the reasons that I can
sit here and talk to guys like tilt and
the French men is because of all the
support that comes in from all of you.
So
appreciate you know that
because as you know,
I don't have any like regular
whatever they're called
advertisements on here,
cause I'm not going to interrupt someone
like tilt or someone like the French or
someone like BTF Tony or
someone like Dakota Meyer.
I'm not going to interrupt
them. So I can say, you know,
hey, buy this or buy that or whatever.
No, I'm not going to stop reading
colder than hell or I'm not going to
stop reading the forgotten Highlander.
I'm not gonna stop reading one
soldiers war so that I can,
you know, mention a product or
something like that. So to me,
that's not what this podcast is about.
The information and yeah,
the information in this podcast is what
is it paramount to me than getting it to
all of you uninterrupted
is what matters.
Because I will tell you that I wish that
I could have listened to this podcast
when I was growing up and were, even
when I was a kid when I was in the teams,
just to,
just to have this information would
have been really helpful to me.
So I'm not keeping it from anyone. So
okay,
that's what we're doing here
through if you do want to help out,
which like I said, that's, that's
what allows us to be able to do this.
That's what allows me to be able to fly
the French men out here to sit down and
and talk and tell his story.
And so it's because of you
all out there supporting,
supporting my companies or my books
or whatever. So it's appreciated.
So if you wanna, if you
do want to help out,
you want to support the podcast,
then you can check on origin maine.com
where we have gies for
Jujitsu, we have rash guards,
we have clothing of all, whatever sorts,
including jeans and we
got supplements up there.
People used to ask me
what supplements I take,
I take the supplements that I make. So
joint warfare, Krill oil discipline,
discipline,
go and I drink milk because it's awesome
and delicious and of course chocolate
white tea. So you can get some
of that. That's all that origin.
maine.com we also have Jocko store.com
where you can get rash guards,
tee shirts,
hats could ease all that stuff.
If you like the podcast, subscribe
to it. And don't forget that.
I also have a kids podcast
called the warrior kid podcast,
so your kids can get in the game too.
That's called the warrior kid podcasts.
Check out warrior kids soap from young
Aiden who's making soap on his farm up in
central California.
That's an Irish oaks ranch.com
there's a youtube channel,
okay.
That's called Jocko podcast and that's
where we have the videos of this.
If you want to see what the Frenchman
looks like or you want to see what tilt
looks like, you can check
out the youtube channel.
There's also little shortened
excerpts of this podcast.
I've got a album called psychological
warfare that's on iTunes,
Google play, other MP3
platforms. It's me talking about
how to overcome little
interruptions in your game
that you're trying to win, so you can
check that and we also have a flip side,
canvas.com my brother Dakota Meyer has
that company and he's making visual
artwork for your walls
that you can hang up.
We also have on it on it.com/jock or
you can get all kinds of cool stuff on
there. Kettlebells, jump ropes,
sandbags, things that you
can get stronger with.
I've also written a bunch of
books. If you want to support,
you can get some of the books way. The
warrior kid is a series of books I wrote.
Okay.
There's three of them. The most
recent one is called wares,
where there is a will and that book is
available right now and so was warrior
way. The where your kid one
and weigh the warrior kid too,
which is subtitled Mark's
mission, Mikey and the dragons,
the book for younger kids that I wrote
so your kids can learn how to overcome
fear. The discipline equals
freedom field manual,
which is a manual about
how to get after it.
All the little questions
that you have are answered.
If you want the audio version of
that, it's on iTunes, Amazon music,
Google play, other MP3 platforms and
of course there's extreme ownership,
which is the first book I wrote with my
brother Leif Babin and then we have a
follow on book to that
called the dichotomy of
leadership and those books are
both about leadership
and how to lead people.
I have a leadership consultancy called
echelon front and what we do is solve
problems through leadership. If
you have problems in your company,
it is because you have problems with
your leadership to go to on front.com if
you want us to come and help you
solve those problems. ETF Online.
This is leadership training online.
It's interactive and I always say
that leadership is not an inoculation.
You can't get one shot of it
and then you know everything.
It's like going to one Jujitsu class and
thinking you know how to choke people
out now. No, you have to
train continually. That's
what ETF online is for.
Its online interactive training e
online.com we've got the muster events.
These are leadership conferences,
musters gatherings where we deep dive and
get granular on the pragmatic tools we
have for leading people. The next
one we're doing is in September,
September 19th and 20th it is in Denver.
It is going to sell out. In fact,
it's getting close I think right now.
Yeah. They've all sold out.
That one will sell out as well and
then December 4th and fifth in Sydney,
Australia. Who knows when we're going
back to Sydney, but we're going this time.
So if you want to come to the monster
checkout extreme ownership.com and then e
f Overwatch for overwatch.com what we're
doing there is taking proven spec ops
leaders,
proven combat aviation leaders and placing
them into companies in the civilian
sector that need leadership. So if you
need leadership in your organization,
go to ESF, overwatch.com
and if you wanna give me some feedback
on this podcast or you have a question or
you have an answer or whatever.
For me, I'm on Twitter, Instagram,
and Facebook at Jocko Willink.
And then once again,
just the deepest thanks I can
give to to John Stryker Meyer tilt
and Doug Letourneau, the Frenchmen
[inaudible]
for doing everything that they did
to fight against the dark
tyranny of communism as it
tried to spread through the
world that they, they the line.
And it's incredible the
operations that they did.
And it's incredible the sacrifices
that those operators made in that time
especially. And obviously the
ones that did not come home.
And to the rest of you that
have served or you are serving.
Thank you for keeping us
safe from today's threats,
which are vast and equally evil.
[inaudible]
it is you that keeps us secure
and keeps our way of life secure into
our police and law enforcement to the
firefighters out there to the paramedics.
EMT is dispatchers, correctional
officers, border patrol,
secret service and and all
other first responders.
You are on call every day.
You are waiting when we
need help, you are there.
So thank you for keeping us safe,
Huh?
And to everyone else out there [inaudible]
don't know.
Remember what the Frenchmen,
remember what the Frenchman said after
his kernel God done explaining the
treacherous situation that
they were set to go into
when that colonel asked if anyone had
any questions, the freshmen replied,
where do you need help?
Where do you need help?
It's a simple question,
but it's a powerful one.
There's people around you that need help.
Ask them what it is they need.
Ask him where it is that they need help
and then get up and lock and load your
sod off.
M 79 or whatever tool it is that you need
to unleash to give them the help that
they need. And until next time,
this is Jocko out. [inaudible].